programming throwdown episode 150 code reviews with on freund take it away patrick well we have a divisible by 10 episode, 150, so that's got to be a positive sign. We made it another... It's not an anniversary? I don't know if you call it another... Decaversary? Jubilee? Oh, that's true. Okay, too soon. Anyways,
欢迎收听编程抛投第150期，本期我们邀请到了安·弗罗因德（An Freund）来聊聊代码评审。掌声有请帕特里克。我们终于迎来了逢10的里程碑集数，第150期，这绝对是个好兆头。我们又坚持了下来……虽然这算不上什么周年纪念？我也不知道该不该把它叫做……十周年纪念？还是某种庆典？哦，也对。好吧，为时尚早。总之，
so we're here to talk about code reviews, which is an awesome topic. Even in the pre-show, I was getting a little excited just hearing some of the thoughts from our guests today. So I'd rather than tee it up and just make everyone really excited you're already here. So we'll just go ahead and go into it. I don't need to pitch an episode coming out next week. It's here. It's now. We're here with An Freund, who is the co-founder and CEO of Wilco. Welcome to the show, An. Thank you so much. Great to be on board.
今天我们来聊聊代码评审，这是一个非常棒的话题。甚至在节目预热时，听到今天嘉宾的一些观点，我就已经开始兴奋了。所以与其由我们来抛砖引玉、把大家胃口吊得老高，不如直接进入正题。我不需要为下周要播出的节目做预告了，因为它就在这里，就在此时此地。今天来到现场的是 Wilco 的联合创始人兼首席执行官安·弗罗因德。欢迎来到节目，安。非常感谢，很高兴能参与录制。
So before we get into the topic, although I'm pretty geared up, I'm not going to lie. I talk a lot about code reviews. So before we get there, let's talk a little bit about you. So we try to ask a lot of our guests. I think it's really interesting. Maybe it's just a very vanity project of mine to sort of like, that's not the right word. Anyways, to just understand a lot about other people and how they sort of developed and got into their current roles. But tell me a little bit about, like, do you remember your first exposure to tech? Like the first time you wrote a program
所以在我们切入正题之前——说实话，我其实已经跃跃欲试了，因为我经常谈论代码评审。不过在此之前，我们先聊聊你个人的经历。通常我们会问嘉宾一些问题，我觉得这非常有趣。也许这只是我个人的某种虚荣心作罢，想要去了解……呃，好像用词不太对。总之，就是想多了解一下其他人以及他们是如何成长并走上目前岗位的。能跟我讲讲你最早接触科技的经历吗？比如你第一次写程序
or the first time you got a computer, like just that memorable sort of early thing that happened? Yeah, it's a great question. If that's your vanity project, you're on the right track. So I think I was around eight years old. I wrote my first computer program in BASIC. And back then in Israel, there was like a famous series of booklets about how to write BASIC. It was called Makhshevet. Everyone who wanted to do anything with a computer in Israel had it. And it was like a series of, I don't know, 15 of them or so. You know, the first one was
或者第一次接触电脑的时候，那些让你记忆犹新的早期经历？是的，这是一个很好的问题。如果这是你的虚荣心项目，那你的方向完全正确。我想我大概是在八岁左右的时候，用 BASIC 语言写下了我的第一个计算机程序。在当时的以色列，有一套非常著名的关于如何编写 BASIC 的小册子，叫做《Mhshevet》。在以色列，任何想用电脑做点什么的人都人手一本。那是一套大约有 15 本左右的书。你知道，第一本
obviously the Hello World program, but then very quickly it progressed. And I actually loved writing games from day one, you know, whether they're text-based or at some point, you know, with actual graphics. But that was always something that, you know, drew me even more than playing games. I think writing games was something that I found really cool awesome i think eight is a bit on the earlier side than a lot of guys earlier than my in mind but this is interesting so there's a booklet was the booklet like a sort of workbook or just like a sort of copy and paste examples i mean both are kind of interesting but what was kind of like the content so a So a lot of it was copy and paste and like the literal sense that, you know, you look at the thing and then you type it. But a lot of it was like fill in the blanks.
显然是“Hello World”程序，但随后进展非常快。其实我从第一天起就非常喜欢写游戏，无论是基于文本的，还是后来带有实际图形的。比起玩游戏，写游戏总是更能吸引我，我觉得这真的是一件非常酷、非常棒的事情。我觉得八岁相对于很多人来说确实有点偏早，比我自己的经历要早。但这很有趣，那本小册子是某种练习册，还是说只是一些复制粘贴的示例？这两种其实都挺有意思的，但具体内容是怎样的？所以，
And some of it, you know, towards the end of every booklet, you'd usually get something that's a bit more adventurous. And you have to start from scratch and build something meaningful. That's awesome. That's not uncommon, actually, this, I guess today you would literally like go to the website and just highlight it and, you know, command C or control C, command V, control V. But like, I think this thing you said, it was true for me as well, like looking in an actual physical book and having to, without errors, type in something and see the magic and debug it. And the booklet thing, I don't know of any, you know, in the United States, any sort of booklet for computer science, but there's a famous one for electronics, which is Forrest Mims. That's even, even pretty,
很大一部分内容确实是复制粘贴，也就是字面意义上的“你看那个代码，然后把它敲进去”。但也有很大一部分是填空题。而且有些内容，在每本小册子的结尾，通常会包含一些更具冒险性的挑战，你必须从头开始构建一些有意义的东西。太棒了！这其实并不少见，我想今天要是在网上，大家也就是直接打开网页高亮选中，然后按 Command C 或 Ctrl C，再 Command V 或 Ctrl V。但我觉得你刚才提到的一点对我也同样适用，那就是看着一本真正的实体书，在不出错的情况下把代码敲进去，然后见证奇迹并进行调试。至于这种小册子，在美国我不知道有没有类似的计算机科学小册子，但有一个非常著名的电子学系列，是福雷斯特·明姆斯（Forrest Mims）写的。那甚至还要更早，
I don't even, I want to say, I was going to guess the decade, but I'll be wrong. So I'll have to look it up later. But in RadioShack, which was like a small chain of electronics hobbyist stores for early computers, they would have these little booklets of circuits. So timers using the 555 integrated circuit or whatever. And it's kind of like what you were saying. People would sort of look at them and you could put them on your breadboard and poke in the little things. Oh, I loved doing of those, you know, electronic kits where you build your own alarm system or radio or whatever. AM radio. Yeah, that was that was cool.
我甚至想猜一下是哪个年代的，但我肯定会猜错，所以我还是以后再去查吧。在当年早期电脑爱好者的电子零件小连锁店 RadioShack 里，他们会有这种关于电路的小册子。比如用 555 集成电路制作定时器之类的。这有点像你刚才说的，人们会翻看这些手册，然后把零件插到面包板上，去戳弄那些小玩意儿。哦，我可太喜欢那些电子套件了，你可以自己组装报警器、收音机什么的，比如调幅收音机。对，那真的太酷了。
I love those. Yeah. In Canada, we had I don't know if we had this in the US, too. We had these books where it was like you'd basically read through this story. And at some point, the story would pause and in the book there would be all this basic code that you would have to type into your computer and the basic code would include like some interactivity so it would ask you like you know like type in like this number and then do this with it and try and solve this little puzzle and then once you got the answer
我太喜欢那些了。对啦，在加拿大——我不知道美国有没有——我们有那种书，基本上就是让你通读一个故事，然后在某个时刻故事会暂停，书中会出现各种 BASIC 代码，你需要把它们输入到你的计算机里。这些 BASIC 代码会包含一些互动性，比如它会要求你“输入这个数字，然后用它做点什么，试着解开这个小谜题”。一旦你得到了答案，
you could flip to the next page and then when you got to the next page they just assumed you got it right it's like you're right it's 21 and half the time i was like oh it's 21 but i got you know syntax error 13 well all right let's keep going and so it's but it's really fun that that's awesome i i love those things if you ever manage to pick up on the name of that of those uh books i'd love to get my hands on let me see if i could do some digging it would be some greatness saja so that's great i thought you were going to tell us like a super clever choose your own adventure like if you put your answer go to that page number and then there'd be like a little debug
你就可以翻到下一页。而当你到了下一页时，它们就默认你已经答对了，上面会写着：“没错，答案就是 21。”但实际上我有一半时间都在想：“哦，答案是 21，但我却遇到了第 13 号语法错误。”好吧，不管怎样，我们继续。不过这真的非常有趣，太棒了！我太喜欢那些东西了。如果你哪天能记起那些书的名字，我真的很想弄一本。我看看能不能去挖一挖，那绝对是一段美好的回忆。太棒了！我还以为你要跟我们讲那种超级聪明的“选择你自己的冒险”式的故事，比如如果你输入了答案就翻到哪一页，然后还会有一个小型的调试
thing like oh you got 17 you messed up order of operations you know you're off by one this page was intentionally left blank oh yeah okay all right so so you're eight you're you're you know copying stuff from these books and learning basic i mean it's awesome um did you kind of fall out of it for a while or did you just kind of continually do some amount of programming through to college? What was your sort of path there? So I did some amount of programming throughout school. In high school, we actually had this thing where in Israel, you have to volunteer for something during high school in at least one of the years. And there are specific things that you can do. And a friend of mine volunteered for like this, this sort of nonprofit that is working on road safety.
环节，像是“哦，你得到了 17，你的运算顺序弄砸了，你差了一位”，而这一页是故意留白的。哈哈，对，好的。所以，你在八岁的时候就开始从这些书里抄代码并学习 BASIC 语言，这真的很棒。嗯，你后来有那么一段时间不再碰它了，还是说从那以后你一直持续做着一定量的编程，直到上了大学？你的经历是怎么样的？我在整个求学期间都保持了一定量的编程。在高中时，我们以色列有个规定：在高中期间的至少某一年，你必须参加某种志愿服务，而且有特定的项目可供选择。我的一个朋友选择加入了一个致力于道路安全的非营利组织做志愿者，
And he was supposed to build a game, like a board game for kids, where that, you know, that teaches road safety. And he reached out to me and said you know what if i build a video game so in addition to my volunteer work i actually ended up uh working on his too and we worked together he was really good with graphics i was good with um with writing code and we built this cool game it had like several levels and the first one was like a walkway. And every time you got the answer right, you would advance to the next block of it. We're not going to talk about what happens if you got it wrong. And the second level was you're like roller skating and you get to street signs and you have to make out which one it is. I don't remember the third level. We actually got together like a few months ago and talked about it.
他需要制作一款游戏，比如一款教导儿童道路安全的棋盘游戏。他找到我问：“如果我做一个电子游戏怎么样？”所以除了我自己的志愿工作之外，我最后还帮他一起做这个项目。我们合作得很好：他很擅长图形设计，而我擅长编写代码。我们做了一款很酷的游戏，它有几个关卡。第一关是一条步行街，每次你答对问题，就能向前推进一个街区。我们就不讨论如果答错会发生什么了。第二关是你扮演轮滑少年，遇到各种街头标志时必须辨认出它们是什么。我不记得第三关是什么了。其实几个月前我们还聚在一起聊过这个呢。
But then after that, it was really cool. We decided, all right, let's build another game. And this one was like a fighting game, like Mortal Kombat style, which was really hot in those days. And we filmed one of our friends against a white sheet. And he kind of went pixel by pixel to get just, you know, just the guy. And we filmed him like, you know, giving out punches and kicks and all of that, and jumping in the air. And we got to a point where we have our friend against like a, like a sketchy bar backdrop.
不过在那之后，真的很酷，我们决定：“好吧，我们来做另一个游戏。”这次是一款格斗游戏，有点像当时非常热门的《真人快打》风格。我们在白床单前拍摄了我们的一个朋友，他逐个像素地抠图，只为了把那个人的形象提取出来。我们拍摄了他出拳、踢腿以及在空中跳跃的各种动作。最后我们做到了这样一个阶段：我们的朋友站在一个有些简陋的酒吧背景前，
And you can make him jump, you can make him kick, you can make him throw a punch. And it was really cool. We never got to the stage where there is another player. So you could just move this guy around and that's it. But it was fun. Yeah, that sounds awesome. Just for posterity's sake the series is called micro adventure and
你可以操控他跳跃、踢腿、出拳。这真的很酷。不过我们从未做到引入第二个玩家的阶段，所以你只能操控这个家伙走来走去，仅此而已。但它真的很有趣。听上去太棒了！为了历史的记录，那个系列的书其实叫做《微型历险记》（Micro Adventure），
it was actually an american thing it was published by scholastic but if folks want to look that up you read these micro adventure books and they have to solve little basic programs along the way but similar to you on i also made a bunch of video games the most infamous one was it was arm wrestling where you had to hit the space bar so many times per second to to you know for so many seconds to arm wrestle victory and the computer lab they broke three keyboards and then that game got banned but i wonder what the equivalent is for nowadays for kids who are you know that the age that we were back then like what is this thing they're tinkering with now but i'm not sure that they create videos
而且这其实是个美国本土的事物，是由学乐（Scholastic）出版的。如果大家想去了解的话，你可以阅读这些《微型历险记》的书，并在阅读过程中解决一些随书出现的小型 BASIC 程序。不过和安你一样，我也做过一束电子游戏。其中最“声名狼藉”的一个是掰手腕游戏，你必须在每秒钟内疯狂猛击空格键无数次，持续好几秒钟，才能在掰手腕中获胜。结果在电脑实验室里，大家砸坏了三个键盘，然后那个游戏就被禁了。我在想，现在的孩子们——也就是我们当年那个年纪的儿童——他们现在的等价物是什么？他们现在都在鼓捣什么东西呢？我不太确定他们是不是在拍视频
on tiktok yeah that's probably but is that is that to the same level of like uh i guess it is kind of a technical thing like it can lead to more technical stuff later yeah and it all depends on you know how far they take it. Right. They can, some of them get really professional and, and, you know, throw in some really cool things, but it's not completely programmable. Maybe I'm blanking on the name, the, the block thing, Minecraft and Minecraft. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. So maybe Minecraft and Roblox are the the closest equivalent these days yeah
发在 TikTok 上。对，那可能……但那达到了那种程度的技术含量吗？我想这确实也算是一种技术相关的东西，它以后可能会引导他们走向更多技术性的领域。是的，这完全取决于他们在这条路上走多远。没错，他们当中有些人会变得非常专业，搞出一些非常酷的东西，但它并不是完全可编程的。也许我想不起那个名字了，就是那个积木拼搭的东西，我的意思是《我的世界》（Minecraft）。对，没错。所以《我的世界》和《罗布鲁斯》（Roblox）可能是如今最接近的替代品了。
makes sense so if you're fighting game on i'm not sure if you were aware at the time or even now but that description of how you did i mean that early motion capture video whatever is how the original mortal combat you know there was some video a few years ago that i think came out where they were showing yeah the person like doing the scenes of that ended up in the in the video game so i don't know did you guys know that or did you like independently just like have this idea well we we assumed i i only caught that video like three months ago i think and and we're talking about more than 20 years back but sure uh we we did assume you know mortal kombat looks like these characters were videoed so we assumed uh that's what was happening and we did know about the green screen technique but we didn't have anything green
很有道理。那么关于你的格斗游戏，安，我不知道你当时是否意识到了，或者现在是否知道，你刚才描述的制作方式——也就是早期那种动作捕捉视频的做法——其实就是初代《真人快打》的做法。几年前曾流出过一些视频，展示了演员在绿幕前完成那些最终被放进游戏里的动作场景。我不知道你们当时是否知道这一点，还是说你们完全是独立想出了这个创意？嗯，我们当时只是假设……其实我大概三个月前才看到那段视频，而我们做游戏已经是二十多年前的事了。不过当然，我们当时确实觉得《真人快打》里的那些角色看起来就像是用摄像机拍出来的，所以我们猜想事情大概就是这样的。而且我们确实知道绿幕技术，但我们当时没有任何绿色的东西，
so we just you know went with white we had to dress him up in very dark uh uniform to make sure that he stands out against the the white background no but that problem solving right i mean like interdiscipline problems. I mean, that's actually like really awesome. And I can totally see like how you end up in a career in tech if that's the kind of things, even if you don't know that's where you're going, if that's the kind of things you're doing,
所以我们只能选了白色。我们不得不让他穿上非常深色的制服，以确保他在白色背景前足够显眼。不过那种解决问题的能力，对吧？也就是跨学科解决问题。我觉得这其实真的很酷。我可以完全理解，如果这就是你当时在做的事情——即使你当时并不知道自己未来会走向何方——你最终是如何走上科技职业道路的。在我的看法里，这感觉就像是一个水到渠成的自然延续。
like it just feels like a natural follow on in my opinion. Yeah, I agree. Okay, so you're in high school helping volunteer stuff, doing this. And then did you end up studying computer science or related field in university? Yeah, I did. I went to Tel Aviv University. I studied computer science, which in retrospect has nothing to do with programming.
是的，我同意。好的，所以你当时在高中做志愿服务，搞这些东西。然后你大学最终选择了计算机科学或相关专业吗？是的，我读了。我去了特拉维夫大学（Tel Aviv University）学习计算机科学，而现在回想起来，这和编程完全没有关系。
It's computer science. These are very different topics. I enjoyed every minute of it. Don't get me wrong. I think computer science is a fascinating topic. And at some point, I was contemplating continuing a more academic path and, you know, actually doing computer science as a career. But, you know, when I got my first real job, I realized that actually nothing that I've learned in college has any bearing towards what I do at work. I think this thing you're saying might be is definitely true.
这是计算机科学，这是两个截然不同的主题。不过我享受其中的每一分钟，别误会我的意思。我认为计算机科学是一个迷人的领域。在某个阶段，我甚至考虑过继续走学术道路，把计算机科学当作真正的职业。但是，当我找到第一份真正的工作时，我意识到我在大学里学到的东西，实际上对我日常的工作没有任何帮助。我觉得你刚才说的这一点绝对是事实。
But it might be a sort of revelation to some people that like going and getting a computer science degree doesn't make you a programmer out the other side. Do you want to elaborate? I mean, I'm happy to elaborate too. But I'll give you the opportunity since you're the guest. Do you want to elaborate like why one isn't equivalent? Sure. So first of all, you know, I'll start by saying that I do recommend people get a computer science degree because I think, like I said, it's awesome. It's interesting. It's a fascinating topic. There are a lot of subtopics within it that you could explore up in college in your job, but it's usually, you know, few and far between. But most of what you learn in school is very theoretical. It actually has nothing to do with computers. Computer science is eventually a branch of math. And large chunks of it deals with hypothetical computers with tapes and operations.
但这对于某些人来说可能是一个巨大的启示：去读一个计算机科学学位并不能让你在毕业时直接变成一个程序员。你想详细阐述一下吗？当然，我也很乐意展开讲讲。不过既然你是嘉宾，我就把机会留给你。你想解释一下为什么这两者不能画等号吗？好的。首先，我先声明一下，我确实推荐大家去攻读计算机科学学位，因为正如我所说，它太棒了、太有趣了，是一个迷人的领域。大学里有很多子领域可供你在求学期间去探索。但在你的工作中，它们通常是凤毛麟角的。你在学校里学到的大多数东西都是非常理论化的，它实际上与计算机本身毫无关系。计算机科学终究是数学的一个分支，其中很大一部分处理的是带有纸带和操作的假想计算机。
So what you learn doesn't necessarily prepare you for the job. And I guess even more importantly, the few things that you do learn that are meaningful are all about code. And the work of a software engineer is way more than code. There are so many skills that go into what you do on a daily basis. Whether it's soft skills, whether it's hard skills, there's just so many of them. And you don't touch any of them in college. Yeah, I agree. I think there's maybe an obvious, but this tension between, as you sort of saying, sort of the mathematical or I don't want to say philosophical, but almost that bent of sort of the mathematical or I don't say philosophical, but almost that bent of sort of how to think about programs as a conceptual sort of underpinning and actually coding or programming. And depending on your university, there may be a balance between them or even different degrees
所以你学到的东西不一定能为你的工作做好准备。而且我想更重要的是，那些你确实学到的、有意义的少数东西全都是关于代码的。但软件工程师的工作远不止代码。日常工作中涉及的技能实在太多了，无论是软技能还是硬技能，种类极其繁多。而在大学里，你根本不会接触到任何这些东西。是的，我完全同意。我觉得这里可能存在一个显而易见但又充满张力的矛盾，正如你所说的那样：一方面是数学的（我不想用“哲学”这个词，但几乎就是那种倾向）或者是如何将程序视为概念基础的思考方式；另一方面则是实际的编码或编程。根据你所读的大学不同，它们之间可能会有一种平衡，甚至在学位内部也有不同的专业方向，
or specialties within the degree that have you doing more of one or more of the other. But I think like you're mentioning, you could take an image processing course and learn all about like theoretical, like binary thresholding of images and never open up OpenCV. And if you go do image processing, like on your own, you're like immediately going to go into a library and sort of be doing image processing tasks. And some universities have tried to adapt to match the expectations, but some have said, wait, that's not our business. Like our business is the business of teaching sort of like you're saying Turing machines
让你侧重于某一方面。但就像你提到的那样，你可能会修一门图像处理课程，学到诸如图像的理论二值化处理之类的内容，却从来没有打开过 OpenCV。如果你自己去搞图像处理，你马上就会引入一个库，然后直接开始处理图像任务。有些大学试图调整自己以迎合这种期望，但也有一些大学会说：“等等，这不是我们的业务。我们的业务是教你图灵机——正如你所说的那样——
or the theoretical differences of a von Neumann architecture versus something else, or talking about compiler languages as like abstract syntax tree manipulation, not sort of the brass tacks of optimization. And so really kind of, I think that's part when you choose a university, that's like a decision you're making when you're choosing what focus you're going to have. But what I, having now being in the role where I interview people coming out of university for working on
或是冯·诺依曼架构与其它架构的理论区别，或者是将编译语言视为抽象语法树的操控，而不是优化的底层细节。”因此，当你选择大学时，这确实是你选择自己未来专注方向时所做出的决定。但是，当我如今扮演着面试那些刚从大学毕业、准备参加工作的新人的角色时……
teams that I'm on and learning is a a couple things that one, not everyone, even at the end, is realizing that they aren't coming out automatically as a programmer. It's not just telling me their curriculum or telling me, even if they did programming as class projects, that's not going to sell me enough on them. That doesn't teach me that they're going to hit the ground running or help me feel confident they're going to hit the ground running. And most of them don't realize, although I have had some candidates kind of self-aware say it that, you know, hey, there's a big difference in university. I was, it's all throwaway. There's like a scaffolding and I do a little fill in the blank. We were kind of talking about that. And then it goes away. Maintenance isn't a concern, even though
我在带团队和学习的过程中发现了几件事。首先，并非每个人，甚至在毕业时，都意识到他们不会自动成为一名程序员。仅仅告诉我他们的课程，或者告诉我他们是否把编程当作课堂项目，这还不足以让我认可他们。这并不能向我证明他们能够迅速上手，或者让我对他们迅速上手充满信心。而且他们大多没有意识到，尽管我确实遇到过一些有自我觉察的候选人，他们会说，你知道的，大学有很大的不同。在大学里，所有东西都是一次性的。就像有一个脚手架，我只需要填空就行了。我们之前讨论过这个。然后它就消失了。维护根本不是一个问题，尽管
we might talk about it, but there's no practice of maintenance. You work on a quote unquote team, but the dynamics, the economics of it, everything is just different. And so maybe it hints at what it would be like. But some people have internships, have that realization. Some have internships, don't quite, but it's just this interesting sort of mix of people and how prepared they come out. And often it's because of work that they took on on their own or on the side and not the curriculum. Exactly. And you know, you come into the first day on the job and you're in the office and, you know, the person welcoming you is probably going to say, hey, why don't you familiarize yourself with the rest of the team? And guess what? You've never learned anything about teamwork. You know, maybe there was like a project that you had to do in a group of four
我们可能会讨论它，但根本没有维护的实践。你在一个所谓的团队里工作，但团队的动力、经济学原理，一切都截然不同。所以这或许暗示了真实的工作会是什么样子。但有些人实习过，意识到了这一点。有些人实习过，还没有完全意识到，这只是一种有趣的人员组合，以及他们准备得如何。通常这是因为他们自己或在业余时间承担的工作，而不是课程本身。完全正确。你知道，你第一天上班走进办公室，欢迎你的人可能会说，嘿，你为什么不先熟悉一下团队的其他成员？你猜怎么着？你从来没有学过任何关于团队合作的知识。你知道，也许你不得不参加一个四人小组的项目
where, you know, two of them were too high to participate and the other person was, you know, banking on you to complete the entire project. So you never really learned how to work in a team. And then maybe go familiarize yourself with a build system and you're like, wait, what is a build system? I've've never done that and this is the way our cicd pipeline works and like wait what and oh by the way we're using git and like what's git you know i've been doing everything on svn and cvs oh awesome okay all right well maybe we keep going because we can't stop here we can't pull
其中两个人太嗨了无法参与，而另一个人则指望你完成整个项目。所以你从未真正学会如何在团队中工作。然后也许让你去熟悉构建系统，你会想，等等，什么是构建系统？我从来没做过这个，这就是我们的CI/CD流水线的工作方式，你会想，等等，什么？哦，顺便说一句，我们在用git，git是什么？你知道的，我以前所有的事情都是在svn和cvs上做的。哦，太棒了，好吧。好吧，也许我们得继续，因为我们不能在这里停下来，我们不能把火车停在
over the train here and uh taking the train stop so we'll go keep going because we can't stop here. We can't pull over the train here and take the train stop. So we'll go keep going. All right. So, so you're studying in university, computer science. Did you, did you kind of like do internships or did you just kind of focus heads down and get through and then, and then enter the workforce? How did that come? And you said you were considering academia. Yeah. So I was, I was actually very, very fortunate. So second year, third semester of school, there's like a career fair.
这里，把火车站搬走，所以我们要继续前进，因为我们不能在这里停下来。我们不能把火车停在这里并占用火车站。所以我们会继续前进。好的。所以你在大学里学习计算机科学。你当时做过实习吗，还是说只是埋头苦读，熬过考试，然后步入职场？这过程是怎样的？你之前说你在考虑学术界。是的。所以，我其实非常幸运。在第二年，也就是学校的第三学期，有一个招聘会。
And it was actually meant mostly for electrical engineering majors. And it was meant for like, you know, seniors. But last minute, I say like, what the heck, let me go there and see what's happening so I go and and I'm late because you know I wasn't intending on going so I'm late the guys are like folding up the booth of a company called Applied Materials and I'm like oh I'm too late and the the guy that was doing the interview is like you know say let me ask you a couple of questions. Let's see if, you know, if it makes sense. And all of the questions he asked me were about operating systems. And I just happened to come out of operating system class, like that day. And all of the questions he asked me were fresh in my brain. So he's like, what is, you know, what's, what's a context switch?
而那个招聘会其实主要是针对电气工程专业的。而且是面向大四学生的。但在最后一关，我想管他呢，让我去看看发生了什么。所以我去了，而且我迟到了，因为我本来没打算去，所以我迟到了。那群人在收起一家名为应用材料（Applied Materials）的公司的展位，我想，哦，我太晚了。那个负责面试的人说，你知道的，让我问你几个问题。看看这是否讲得通。他问我的所有问题都是关于操作系统的。而我刚好那天刚上完操作系统课。他问的所有问题都在我的脑海里记忆犹新。所以他说，你知道什么是上下文切换吗？
And which, by the way, developers today probably don't even know what it is, but because they're lucky enough to be in higher level languages, but what's the context switch? And I look at, look at him and I'm like, are you kidding me? Because it's so fresh in my brain that I think that it's common knowledge. Are you kidding me? And he's like, no, what is it? And so I give a perfect answer, you know, and he's like no what is it and so i give a perfect answer uh you know and he's like so he writes down and i know this because he told me afterwards he writes down
顺便说一句，今天的开发人员可能甚至不知道那是什么，因为他们足够幸运，能够使用更高级别的语言，但什么是上下文切换？我看着他，心想，你在开玩笑吧？因为这在我的脑海里太新了，以至于我认为这是常识。你在开玩笑吧？他说，不，那是什么？所以我给出了一个完美的回答，你知道，他说，不，那是什么？所以我给出了一个完美的回答，你知道，他写下了……我知道这是因为他事后告诉我，他写下了
very cocky but knows his knows his stuff um from the sound of it yeah in retrospect this was he got it completely right we're actually very good friends now till this day. And this was, you know, almost 20 years ago. So he writes this down in his notebook. And then a few days later, I get a call. And they're like, why don't you come over for an interview and interview and I managed to get the job and I start working, you know, this was like, you know, in the break, the winter break between the third and fourth semester, I start working. So I never really had an internship per se. But I was working throughout the second half of my degree. Oh, awesome. So you were like working part time while doing school? Yeah. Oh, nice, nice. Oh, and what and so that company, they were pretty low level if they're
非常傲慢，但听起来确实懂行。从语气听来是这样。是的，回想起来，他完全说对了。直到今天，我们其实是非常要好的朋友。而这已经是差不多20年以前的事了。所以他在笔记本上记下了这一点。几天后，我接到一个电话。他们说，你为什么不过来面试呢？我设法得到了这份工作，开始工作。你知道，这大约是在第三和第四学期之间的寒假，我开始工作了。所以我从来没有真正意义上的实习。但在我学业的后半段，我一直在工作。哦，太棒了。所以你是一边上学一边做兼职？是的。哦，不错，不错。哦，那家公司，他们做的是相当底层的工作吗，如果他们
asking about operating system and context switching? Yeah. So Applied Materials is in the semiconductor industry. And what they do is they make machines that either build or test or do anything in the manufacture of chips. So specifically, the team that I was working on was building this machine that could do two things. It was like an attempt to take two machines and turn them into one. So there was one machine that is measuring, say the distance between two conductors to make sure that the board was printed right. And, you know, we're talking those distances, obviously it's, it's microns, right?
问到操作系统和上下文切换的话题？是的。应用材料公司属于半导体行业。他们制造的机器用于芯片制造过程中的构建、测试或任何其他环节。具体来说，我当时所在的团队正在制造一台能够做两件事的机器。这就像是试图把两台机器合二为一。有一台机器负责测量，比如两个导体之间的距离，以确保电路板打印正确。而且，我们谈论的这些距离，显然是微米级的，对吧？
Sure, sure, sure. So there was like this crazy electron microscope and, and all of that. And the other machine was classifying defects. So you know that there is a defect in the wafer that so you know what happened wrong during the manufacturing process and we were building a machine that is trying to do both so there was a lot of image processing there was a lot of controlling the machinery you know you had like basically a robot that is taking one wafer while taking the other wafer out because you didn't want to waste time this is like the manufacturing floor. Everything needs to be super efficient. So you had, you know, these arms that
当然，当然，当然。所以那里有一个疯狂的电子显微镜之类的设备。另一台机器则负责分类缺陷。你知道晶圆上有一个缺陷，所以你知道制造过程中出了什么问题。我们正在制造一台试图兼顾这两者的机器。那里有大量的图像处理，有大量的机械控制，你知道，基本上有一个机器人，它在拿出一片晶圆的同时放入另一片晶圆，因为你不想浪费时间。这就是制造车间。一切都需要超级高效。所以你有，你知道，这些机械臂
are bringing in one wafer, taking the other one out. And there's like a chamber in between where they, you know, it's like, it's like those spaceships where you need like a double latch. Oh yeah. It's gotta be vacuumed down. Yeah. Yeah. Because everything is like super clean. You can't have any, you know, any particles of dust in there. So it was it was pretty wild and pretty low level. It was fun. But I vowed not to do low level since and I like many promises I made in my life didn't actually live up to it. Okay, so you and I can't be friends, but okay. So we won't get sidetracked there either. So you're doing this, you're finishing up your degree. And then it sounds like maybe you decided not to go there when you graduated,
把一片晶圆放进去，把另一片拿出来。中间有一个舱室，它们，你知道，就像那些需要双重锁存器的宇宙飞船一样。哦，是的。必须抽真空。是的。是的，因为一切都超级干净。里面不能有任何灰尘颗粒。所以这相当疯狂，而且相当底层。这很有趣。但我发誓从那以后再也不做底层工作了，和生活中的许多承诺一样，我并没有真正兑现它。好吧，所以你和我不能做朋友了，不过好吧。我们也不会扯远了。所以你在做这个，你快完成学位了。然后听起来你可能决定毕业后不留在那里，
or kind of take us through what happened next. So when I was close to graduation, I decided that Applied Materials is no longer for me. Applied Materials is a Fortune 500 company. It's huge. It's American. I wanted to join an Israeli startup. I'm based in Israel. I want to be where decisions are being taken, et cetera. And I joined a small startup. It was about 20 people. It was in the cybersecurity space. And I joined the server team because I didn't want to do low level anymore. So I'm on the server team. I didn't want to do low level anymore, right? So I'm on the server team, I'm writing.NET code, and no need to manage memory, all of that. And what we were doing is this product that lets CISOs control what's happening in the organization in terms of external devices and content. So you can't copy those files over to a USB, you can't send that type
或者跟我们讲讲接下来发生了什么。当我快毕业时，我决定应用材料公司不再适合我。应用材料公司是一家财富500强公司。它太庞大了。它是美国的。我想加入一家以色列的初创公司。我的基地在以色列。我想身处决策制定的地方，等等。于是我加入了一家小型初创公司。大约有20人。它属于网络安全领域。我加入了服务器团队，因为我不想再做底层工作了。所以我在服务器团队，我不想再做底层工作了，对吧？所以我加入了服务器团队，我编写.NET代码，不需要管理内存，诸如此类。我们正在做的是这样一个产品，它让CISO（首席信息安全官）能够控制组织内外部设备和内容方面发生的事情。所以你不能把这些文件复制到USB上，你不能发送那种类型
of content over email, et cetera, et cetera. And what do you know, within a year, I find myself in the agent team writing Windows kernel drivers. Sounds like you didn't last long in your avoidance, so you must have some skill there, I guess. I hated it. You know, when you write Windows kernel drivers, you know, today it's somewhat easier because a lot of it could be done with virtual machines. But because we were dealing so much with hardware, you know, many of the things we did
的内容通过电子邮件，等等，等等。你猜怎么着，不到一年，我就发现自己身处代理团队，编写Windows内核驱动程序。听起来你在避免底层工作这件事上没坚持多久，所以我猜你在那方面肯定有两下子。我讨厌它。你知道，当你编写Windows内核驱动程序时，现在这相对容易一些，因为很多工作可以通过虚拟机完成。但因为我们处理了太多硬件相关的事情，你知道，我们所做的很多事情
actually meant that we had to have another computer to test what we're building on. And, you know, your actual computer and the other computer are connected through a serial cable, because that's the only way to debug kernel drivers. And any bug, or almost any bug would cause a blue screen of death. And, you know, sometimes the cycle of blue screens of death, where you actually have to wipe the hard drive clean and start from scratch. And this was just, you know, that's where I learned the importance of a really short feedback cycle. You know, when you're writing a driver and everything that you do wrong,
实际上意味着我们必须有另一台计算机来测试我们正在构建的东西。而且，你知道，你的实际计算机和另一台计算机是通过串口电缆连接的，因为那是调试内核驱动程序的唯一方法。任何错误，或者几乎任何错误都会导致蓝屏死机。而且，你知道，有时蓝屏死机的循环意味着你实际上必须彻底擦除硬盘并从头开始。这只是，你知道，正是在那里我学到了一个极短的反馈周期的重要性。你知道，当你编写驱动程序时，你所做的任何错误，
takes you like two hours to, you know, get something new on that computer to test it again. It's just so frustrating. Yeah, I think also the other thing that you're mentioning, which is kind of interesting, like nowadays or most development, I guess, takes place in an app running in your computer. And the goal of the operating system in part is to prevent the app from crashing the operating system.
都需要你花大约两个小时才能把新东西放到那台计算机上再次测试。这实在是太令人沮丧了。是的，我觉得你提到的另一件事也很有趣，就像现在或大多数开发工作一样，我想，都是在运行在你电脑上的应用程序中进行的。操作系统的部分目标是防止应用程序使操作系统崩溃。
And so, or one of the many goals. But this level you're talking about is lower than that. So those protections aren't in place for efficiency reasons for whatever. And over time, they've tried to kind of get better at it, as you've said, like you're over some serial cable or USB to a tiny little board. And if you screw up, like, you know, who knows what's going on? You know, you're trying to like get commands out. You're probing it with like a little multimeter or an oscilloscope trying to like move a line up and down to say that you're alive and still running. The one thing they do have going for them is that boot times are faster. Other than that, it's just like those days of Windows drivers. But you know,
因此，这是众多目标之一。但你所说的这个级别比那还要低。因此，出于效率或其他原因，这些保护措施并没有到位。随着时间的推移，正如你所说，他们试图在这方面做得更好，比如你通过一些串口电缆或USB连接到一个微型小板上。如果你搞砸了，天知道发生了什么？你知道，你试图发出命令。你用一个小型万用表或示波器去探测它，试图上下移动一条线路，以说明你还活着并且仍在运行。他们唯一占优势的是启动时间更快。除此之外，就像那些Windows驱动程序的日子一样。但你知道，
Windows could take two minutes to boot. That was another point of frustration. And, you know, you said that you're, you know, lower level than the operating system in many cases, you know, the crazy thing is, sometimes when you're writing Windows drivers, you're in a higher priority than the memory pager, which means that you can't use certain types of memory because your code can't be interrupted. Like the processor is going to prevent your code from being interrupted in order to fetch memory from disk so that means you have to do with only memory that is available in your ram this this is hell like if you can avoid it please do oh i thought we're gonna get a chance to talk about it i mean i have a bad anecdote one time
Windows可能需要两分钟才能启动。这是另一个令人沮丧的点。而且，你知道，你刚才说，在许多情况下，你比操作系统还要底层，你知道，最疯狂的是，有时当你编写Windows驱动程序时，你的优先级比内存页面调度程序还要高，这意味着你不能使用某些类型的内存，因为你的代码不能被中断。就像处理器会阻止你的代码被中断，以便从磁盘获取内存，这意味着你只能处理RAM中可用的内存，这简直是人间地狱，如果能避免，请千万别做。哦，我还以为我们有机会谈谈这个呢。我的意思是，我有一个糟糕的轶事，有一次
about spending several we can talk about it i'm'm saying you should avoid it as a profession, but as a discussion topic, sure. Several weeks spent debugging an intricacy between a deadlock of two interrupts at slightly different parties that were not at the parties they were supposed to be, and one was interrupting the other. And it just created a sort of cascade where it kept interrupting it, which would fill up the stack. But of course, none of that's obvious, right? And so, yeah. I have a similar kind of story to you on. Patrick and I worked at a place where we did a lot of embedded, but I didn't do a lot of embedded.
花了几个星期来调试两个中断之间的死锁错综复杂的关系，这两个中断在稍微不同的各方，而这些各方本不该是这样的，其中一个中断了另一个。它只是产生了一种级联效应，不断地中断它，从而填满了堆栈。但当然，所有这些都不是显而易见的，对吧？所以，是的。我和你有一个类似的故事。帕特里克和我曾在一家公司工作过，我们做了很多嵌入式开发，但我没有做太多嵌入式开发。
And so I was writing these kind of like, I was in a space where we had, you know, gigabytes of memory. And so it wasn't an issue and at some point someone asked me to do something on a dsp and uh yeah i just i couldn't do it i was like you know i just i started like i was like oh i'll make all these structures and i'll just have this like linked list and this tree and i'll manage everything and then i it's like oh your program won't actually fit on the chip. And I was like, wait, what? I was like, oh, yeah, I guess the program itself takes space.
所以我写的那种……我身处一个拥有千兆字节内存的空间里。所以这不是问题，在某个时候，有人要求我在DSP上做一些事情，然后，是的，我实在做不到了。我想，你知道，我刚开始时想，哦，我要制作所有这些结构，我要有这样的链表和树，我要管理一切。然后我想，哦，你的程序实际上装不进芯片里。我就想，等等，什么？我就想，哦，是的，我想程序本身是占用空间的。
And I was way out of my league. I was like, Patrick, bail me out. Somebody help me. All right. All right. So, okay, keep going. So you're at a cybersecurity firm. You're writing agents.
我完全超出了我的能力范围。我说，帕特里克，救救我。谁来帮帮我。好啦，好啦。所以，好吧，继续。所以你在一家网络安全公司。你在编写代理。
So like things that run on the Windows computers and then get managed up. And then from there, sort of how to do what came next? Yeah. So by the way, after that, I once again, vowed not to do any type of low level programming and failed once again, to keep my promise. But this time, it's, it's, you know, a bit more elective. So I'm, I do a lot of home automation, and I end up writing a lot of code that actually deals with hardware in my home. Sometimes I have to reverse engineer the protocols that they use. But anyway, so after that, I was with that company for about seven years in total. It was acquired at some point.
也就是在Windows计算机上运行并进行集中管理的东西。然后从那里，接下来发生了什么？是的。顺便说一句，在那之后，我再次发誓不再做任何类型的底层编程，结果再次食言了。但这一次，它，你知道的，更具选择性。所以我在做很多家庭自动化，我最终写了很多实际处理我家硬件的代码。有时我不得不逆向工程他们使用的协议。不管怎样，在那之后，我在那家公司呆了总共大约七年。它在某个时候被收购了。
I stayed with the acquirer. But at the same time, I also moved to New York. And after leaving the acquiring company, I joined a small startup called Handy. And Handy is kind of like Uber for home services. So you can book someone to come clean your home, etc, etc. It was a very small startup. And we were like four people. And I joined as VP of engineering. And I was supposed to build an engineering team and start, you know, making sure this thing actually works. And, and, you know, finally, I'm in the clear, and I'm writing high level server, backend code, you know, I started hiring people. And, you know, once again, I witnessed that, you know, coming out of college
我留在了收购方。但与此同时，我也搬到了纽约。在离开被收购的公司后，我加入了一家名为Handy的小型初创公司。Handy有点像家政服务领域的Uber。所以你可以预约某人来打扫你的家，等等，等等。那是一家非常小的初创公司。我们大约有四个人。我作为工程副总裁加入了公司。我本应建立一个工程团队并开始，你知道，确保这东西真正起作用。而且，你知道，终于，我重获自由，我正在编写高级服务器后端代码，你知道的，我开始招募人员。而且，你知道，我再次目睹了，大学毕业
and not being prepared for work kind of thing now as a hiring manager, but very similar to what I experienced on my first day on the job. And I did that for a couple of years and then once again transitioned to WeWork where I was initially VP of engineering as well. That was a wild ride. That's material for a 90-minute long episode for sure.
并且没有为工作做好准备的那种情况，现在我作为招聘经理看到了，这和我第一天上班时的经历非常相似。我做了几年，然后再次转型去了WeWork，我最初也是那里的工程副总裁。那是一段疯狂的旅程。这绝对是制作一个90分钟长节目的好素材。
Probably, you know, way more than that. Yeah, I think we'll just not have to go on to that one. Yeah, okay, keep going. And, you know, did that and spent a few years at WeWork. That was actually really cool. We've built some really amazing tech. You know, people always ask, why does WeWork even need tech? But I can honestly say that some of the things that we've built are groundbreaking. And, you know, even things as mundane as making
可能吧，你知道，远不止这些。是的，我想我们就不必深入讨论那个了。是的，好吧，继续。而且，你知道，做完了那个，并在WeWork度过了几年。那其实真的很酷。我们构建了一些非常棒的技术。你知道，人们总是问，为什么WeWork甚至需要技术？但我可以诚实地说，我们构建的一些东西是具有突破性的。而且，你知道，甚至像是让
sure that key cards, key cards actually work. So if you've ever been to a hotel, you know that they don't work in like, at least 20% of the cases, whereas at WeWork, they always work, and you can actually switch buildings and switch companies and even visit a building that you're not a part of. And if you have a booking there, it's going to open. So we built a lot of really cool things, both software and hardware to make these things work. And after leaving WeWork, I spent a few more years. I was six years at WeWork and I've done more than just engineering at some point and moved
确保门禁卡，门禁卡确实能用。所以如果你去过酒店，就会知道它们在至少20%的情况下是失灵的，而在WeWork，它们总是管用，你实际上可以切换大楼、切换公司，甚至去参观一栋你并不属于的大楼。如果你在那里有预订，门就会打开。所以我们构建了很多非常酷的东西，包括软件和硬件，来让这些功能正常运转。离开WeWork之后，我又度过了几年。我在WeWork呆了六年，在某个阶段，我做的事情不仅仅是工程，还转向了不同的角色。但离开WeWork后，我作为VC进行了一次短暂的、非常短暂的尝试，但觉得创始人的人生对我来说是更好的生活。就在那时，我们创立了Wilco。
on to different roles. But after leaving WeWork, I did a short, very short stint as a VC, but decided that the life of a founder is a better life for me. And that's when we started Wilco. Okay, awesome. Well, we're going to come back to Wilco at the end. So we'll put a pin in that. And I think this observation that you made is people saying, oh, what kind of tech do you have to build for insert company here? And I think that at some level, people say tech is changing the world and things are, but then this thing you're elaborating like key card example, just as the thing is, you think it's just a commoditized product at this point.
好的，太棒了。嗯，我们最后会回到Wilco的话题上来。所以我们先把这个放一放。我觉得你的这个观察是，人们会说，哦，针对某某公司，你得构建什么样的技术？我认为在某种程度上，人们说技术正在改变世界，事实也确实如此，但接着你刚才阐述的这种事情，比如门禁卡的例子，就像是，你觉得到了这个阶段，它已经变成了一个商品化的产品。
But then are you even mentioning about home automation? And most people's home automation experience just tell them it doesn't actually just work. And so you run into all of these for no fault of necessarily the product provider, but they're fine tuning for like a specific use case and sometimes overly so. And if you're just outside of that
但接着你甚至提到了智能家居？而大多数人的智能家居体验只会告诉他们，它其实并不好用。所以你会遇到所有这些问题——不一定是因为产品提供商的错，而是因为他们在针对某个特定用例进行微调，有时甚至有些过度微调。如果你刚好处在那个范围之外，
or two steps outside of it, you sort of end up on your own. They're happy to sell you their product and it'll do maybe the thing it says on the package outside of that, or two steps outside of it, you sort of end up on your own, they're well, they're happy to sell you their product. And it'll do maybe the thing it says on the package, or you can hold them to it. But if you want to use it in a new application or a new way, you're sort of left out on alert yourself and sort of adapting it or adding front ends or gluing it together in some way or interfacing systems. And that's a bit of a recurring theme. And so yeah, I'm not surprised to hear you say that, but it is great to hear such a sort of,
或者偏离了两步，你基本上就得靠自己了。他们很乐意把产品卖给你，它或许能实现包装上写的功能，超出这个范围，或者偏离了两步，你基本上就得靠自己了，他们，嗯，他们很乐意把产品卖给你。它或许能实现包装上写的功能，你可以找他们理论。但如果你想把它用在一个新的应用场景或新的方式中，你某种程度上就被晾在一边，只能靠自己去适应、添加前端、以某种方式将它们拼凑在一起，或者实现系统间的接口对接。这是一个有点反复出现的主题。所以，是的，听到你这么说我并不感到意外，但听到这样一个，
I think, understandable example. Yeah, and that's what makes, we're going completely off topic, but that's what makes build versus buy decisions so complicated because sometimes you have a product that is the leader in the space and supposedly great, but your use case is, like you said, just not the right use case for it. And, you know, sometimes you can adapt what you're doing
我觉得很好理解的例子，真的很棒。是的，这就是为什么——我们要彻底跑题了——但这就是为什么“自研还是购买”的决定会如此复杂，因为有时你拥有的产品是该领域的佼佼者，而且据称很棒，但你的用例，就像你说的，偏偏不适合它。而且，你知道，有时你可以调整你正在做的事情，
and then, you know, just buy it and use it off the shelf. But sometimes what you're doing is unique and enough and not adaptable that you just have to build your own and, you know, always have to be very careful to make sure that you're not, you not invented here biases that are causing you to build this yourself. But sometimes it is the rational decision to build something that already exists. You are right. And I think making sure you've avoided the biases is a bit of a trick there. But yeah, it's very difficult. Okay. Well, to finally get to the- Trying to avoided the biases is is a bit of a trick there but uh yeah it's very difficult okay well to finally trying to avoid the biases maybe maybe that's a better a better way to phrase it
然后，你知道，直接买现成的来用就行了。但有时你做的事情足够独特，无法适应，以至于你只能自己造轮子，而且，你知道，总是必须非常小心，确保不是因为“非我所创”的偏见在驱使你自己去搞这个。但有时，自己造一个已经存在的东西确实是理性的决定。你是对的。我认为确保自己避免了这些偏见本身就是一个小技巧。不过，是的，这非常困难。好吧，最后来到——试图避免偏见本身就是一个小技巧，但——是的，这非常困难。好吧，为了最后——试图避免偏见，也许，也许这是更好的表述方式
doing your best doing your best yeah uh okay so finally here we go we're here it's time we're going to talk about this so uh code review we already i think even set it up unintentionally not that it was the purpose of the lead in, but already sort of talking about students coming out of college, talking about, you know, expectations that are unobvious. I think several of those sort of TS up or describe sort of code review. If you sort of type in,
尽力而为，尽力而为，是的，嗯，好吧，所以最后，我们来了，我们在这儿，是时候了，我们要谈谈这个了——所以，嗯，代码审查。我想我们之前甚至在无意中就铺垫过了，倒不是说这是引导谈话的目的，但我们已经在讨论刚毕业的学生了，在讨论那些显而易见却又容易被忽视的期望。我觉得其中好几个点都在为代码审查做铺垫或进行描述。如果你在搜索引擎里输入，
I don't know. I haven't tried it. If you type into the search engine, define code review, I'm sure you get back something that probably adequately describes the gist, but it doesn't capture the essence, right? Code review is a bit more than just the most obvious, like I show you my code
我不知道。我没试过。如果你在搜索引擎里输入“定义代码审查”，我确信你能得到一些大概能恰当描述其要领的内容，但它抓不住精髓，对吧？代码审查不仅仅是最明显的那种——我把代码展示给你，
and you grade it like a school paper. I think there's a bit more to that. And I think this is gonna tee up the discussion. So I'll give you the opening argument here on or opening discussion about, you know, how do you think about code reviews? Well, you know, I actually like to start with a topic that's early discussed,
然后你像批改学校作业一样给我打分。我觉得其中还有更多的内容。我想这会为接下来的讨论做好铺垫。所以我把开场白交给你，关于——你如何看待代码审查？嗯，你知道，我其实喜欢从一个很少被讨论的话题开始，
which is why code reviews, right? And if, like you said, you type in code review into search engines, you're actually going to find a lot of content on how. You know, these are the best practices when reviewing code. This is what we do at Company X to review our code. But why are you using code reviews? you get into that, there's a whole world where you start to realize, wait, how am I even taking someone else's workflow when our motivations are completely different? And sometimes you'll find that even within a single company, the motivations for code review are different between teams.
那就是为什么要进行代码审查，对吧？如果像你所说的那样，你在搜索引擎里输入“代码审查”，你实际上会找到大量关于“如何做”的内容。你知道，这些是审查代码的最佳实践。我们在X公司就是这样审查代码的。但你为什么要进行代码审查？一旦你深入探讨这一点，就会进入一个全新的世界，你会开始意识到，等一下，当我们双方的动机完全不同时，我怎么能原封不动地采用别人的工作流程呢？有时你会发现，即使在同一家公司内部，不同团队进行代码审查的动机也是不同的。
Now, if you ask most people, I would assume that a lot of them are going to think that finding bugs before they make it to production is a motivation for code reviews. And that's something I don't like, to be honest, because I think there are better ways to find bugs. Now, I'm not saying that if you find a bug in a code review, you should ignore it. I'm just saying that, you know, finding a bug in a code review is finding it too late in many cases, right? You want to find those way before that stage. A code review involves another person. You want to find that before you involve another person, unless you're pair programming. Yeah, I think just on that before you keep going, i think that this thing is interesting i've had
现在，如果你问大多数人，我猜他们中的很多人会认为，在代码进入生产环境之前找出Bug是代码审查的动机。说实话，我不太喜欢这种说法，因为我认为有更好的方法来找Bug。现在，我并不是说如果你在代码审查中发现了Bug就该无视它，我只是说，你知道，在代码审查中发现Bug，在很多情况下已经发现得太晚了，对吧？你希望远在那个阶段之前就把它们找出来。代码审查涉及另一个人。你希望在涉及另一个人之前就把Bug找出来，除非你在进行结对编程。是的，我觉得就在这一点上，在你继续之前，我觉得很有趣的一点是，我曾遇到过这样的情况：
occurrences where i've reviewed someone's code and missed a bug and they want to share responsibility they're so so gracious right well you reviewed the code and so therefore you know you should have known it didn't do anything or didn't compile or didn't work and i sort of you know that that conversation that missed expectation about what was happening. But this thing is that even at the time, maybe I didn't spend infinite amounts of time and try to come through it or redo all their own work. But sort of setting up those expectations and making sure that the team shares them. But yeah, this one in specific, like that if you review your code, if you don't catch the bug, it becomes like your bug too. That's a bit of a hard arrangement to have.
我审查了别人的代码却漏掉了一个Bug，而他们却想让我分担责任，他们是如此地宽容，对吧？“嗯，你审查了代码，所以理所当然地，你知道它什么都没做、或者没通过编译、或者根本不工作。”然后我就——你知道，那场对话、对正在发生的事情产生的不符合实际的期望。但关键是，即使在当时，也许我也并没有花无限的时间去仔细翻看或者重新做他们所有的工作。而是要设定好这些期望，并确保团队对此达成共识。但是，是的，这个特定的事情，就像如果你审查了代码，如果没有抓到Bug，它也变成你的Bug了一样。这可真是一个让人难以接受的安排。
Yeah, that's a bit extreme. But you mentioned the word share, which I think is really important in this context, because code review is a lot about sharing. And to me, one of the biggest motivations is creating that shared ownership of the code, not shared ownership of the bugs necessarily. And I don't think people should own bugs. I think they should own up to them. But it's about creating that shared ownership of the code. And this is actually something that both the reviewer and the reviewee can take. Because if I'm reviewing your code and you might be working in this company
是的，这有点极端。但你提到了“分担”这个词，我认为在语境中这非常重要，因为代码审查很大程度上关乎分享。对我和而言，最大的动机之一就是建立对代码的共同所有权，不一定是分担Bug的所有权。我不认为人们应该拥有Bug。我认为他们应该勇于承担。但这是为了建立对代码的共同所有权。这其实是审查者和被审查者双方都能获得的收获。因为如果我在审查你的代码，而你可能已经在这家公司
or on this code base for four years and I'm just coming in and I'm reviewing your code, I'm actually learning a lot through it. I'm learning, first of all, how are you used to working? And maybe I'm used to a different workflow. And I'm learning about the patterns that you like in the code base. And I'm learning about the patterns that you like in the code base. And I'm learning
或这个代码库工作了四年，而我刚刚加入进来并审查你的代码，我实际上能从中学到很多。首先，我了解了你的工作习惯是什么样的。也许我习惯了不同的工作流程。我了解了你在代码库中偏爱的模式。我了解了你在代码库中偏爱的模式，而且我正在了解
some of the gotchas that I might find in this code. So reviewing is actually a great way to read code. And reading code is a great way to familiarize yourself with the system, right? And you can't just go around reading code, but you can go around reading changes. That, you know, is a great way, I would say, if you're starting, reviewing code is actually a great way to start. Now, some people might balk at that. And, you know, they'll say, wait, but the person reviewing should know better than the person who's being reviewed. And you know what, that's not always the case. And, you know, in many companies, there's someone at the top of the pyramid, someone needs to review their code right uh ai that's we have ai for it um no i
我可能会在这个代码库中遇到的某些“坑”。所以，审查代码其实是阅读代码的绝佳途径，而阅读代码则是熟悉系统的好方法，对吧？你不能只是到处去读代码，但你可以到处去读代码变更。你知道，如果你刚开始上手，审查代码其实是一个极好的切入点。现在，有些人可能会对此感到排斥，并且，你知道，他们会说，“等等，但审查代码的人应该比被接受审查的人水平更高才对。”你知道吗？事实并非总是如此。而且，你知道，在许多公司里，金字塔顶端总得有人去审查他们的代码吧，呃，AI，我们有AI来做这个——不，我
think i think this observation is great and i think so two things one is like you can have more than one person review your code so there's always that but i do agree with this and the other thing that being thoughtful about this when you decide how to group stuff for a let's just say we're using a git workflow or whatever you know for a pull request or you know that that's that's what we're going to take how do you decide when to stop and when to do that and making sure that you are not just doing that for your own convenience, but for the convenience of reviewers. And further, I agree with this point that like, doing it such that a new person has a sort of self contained snippet narrative that takes them through, you know, hopefully, we're all we're going to assume some good software practices here assumption is like, you're seeing that maybe the
觉得，我觉得这个观察太棒了，而且我有两点看法。第一，你可以让不止一个人来审查你的代码，所以总是有这种机制的。但我确实同意这一点。另一点是，在决定如何将内容分组时要深思熟虑——比方说我们使用的是Git工作流或其他什么工具，你知道，为了一个Pull Request（拉取请求），或者，你知道，这就是我们要采用的方式——你如何决定何时停止、何时进行审查，并确保你这样做不仅是为了自己的方便，也是为了审查者的方便。不仅如此，我还赞同这样一点：这样做可以让新人获得一种自包含的代码片段叙事，引导他们浏览——希望我们在这里都认同一些良好的软件工程实践，假设比如，你看到
person added a unit test for the failure that they were fixing or a test for a new feature they were adding. You see the code that was changed. You see how many places and what parts of the system got affected by that particular feature or that particular thing. And it becomes this self-contained, encapsulated description. Now, not all pull requests would be like that, but I think a large amount of them can become this very
这个人为你正在修复的故障添加了单元测试，或者为他们正在添加的新功能添加了测试。你能看到被修改的代码。你能看到该特定功能或特定事项影响了多少地方以及系统的哪些部分。它就变成了一个自包含的、封装好的描述。现在，并非所有的Pull Request都会是这样的，但我认为其中很大一部分都可以变成这种非常
readable thing. If you try to make sure you divide up your work in a way that the stream is readable, you're doing a great service to the people who are coming after you. Exactly. If you need to familiarize yourself with a code base, that's a
可读性强的东西。如果你努力确保以一种让代码流具有可读性的方式来划分你的工作，你就是在为后来者做一件大好事。没错。如果你需要熟悉一个代码库，
tough thing to do. You probably need some combination of top-down and bottom-up, right? You need to understand the architecture of that code base. And that's sort of the top-down approach. And you see how things communicate with each other, which components are there, et cetera, et cetera. But then you also need that bottom-up. And I think that reading past reviews is actually a great way to familiarize yourself with a given code base and and the given practices around it which are just as important i have uh i'm not the best at this but i have consulted old code reviews of
这可是一件难事。你可能需要自顶向下和自底向上相结合的方法，对吧？你需要了解该代码库的架构。这就是所谓的自顶向下的方法。你能看到事物之间是如何通信的、有哪些组件，等等，等等。但同时你也需要自底向上的方法。而且我认为，阅读过去的审查记录其实是熟悉给定代码库以及与其相关的重要实践的绝佳途径。我有一个——我在这方面并不是做得最好，但我曾参考过自己或其他人过去的旧代码审查记录，仅仅为了回忆起哪些部分需要再次被修改，看看当时是谁发表了评论并说：“哦，是的，以后这里需要调整”或者类似的话，然后我就想：“哦，我现在又在做了，当时那并没有写进代码里”，虽然它不一定适合作为代码注释，但让我回头看看当时的代码审查记录，看看我们讨论了什么，我们对于“嘿，下次我们接触这个时，考虑这样做”是怎么想的，啊，原来在这里。所以，即使团队中现在没有人正在学习或处于那个阶段，
myself or others for just remembering which pieces need to go get changed again and seeing who commented on the time and said like oh yeah in the future this needs to shift or this and i'm like oh i'm doing it again now that didn't make it in the code it's necessarily appropriate as like a code comment but let me go back to the review that happened at the time and see what did we discuss what was our thought about about, hey, next time we visit this, let's consider doing, and ah, there it is. And so even if there isn't people on the team right now learning or in that stage,
是的，未来完全可能会有人去阅读你以前的代码审查记录以及你的编写过程，不仅看你写在代码里的东西，还要看人们是如何与这个过程互动并观察它的。没错。所以，你知道，这是一种动机，但我还能想到许多其他动机，你可能会出于这些动机去进行代码审查。你知道，其中另一个动机可能是代码质量。所以你可以自动化处理其中的一部分，但有些部分，你知道，你希望人类来看一眼代码并说：“好吧，我姑且假设代码实现了它所宣称的功能，对吧？但它够好吗？它具可维护性吗？这是我们想要引入代码库的东西吗？”这就是，你知道的，进行代码审查的另一个极好的动机。还有很多不同的方面，你知道，它安全吗？那里是否存在任何性能影响？有太多不同的事情
yeah, there could totally be in the future people reading your old code reviews and the process you, what you're writing in the code, but also how people are interacting with that process and observing it. Exactly. So, you know, that's one motivation, but I can think of so many other motivations that you might want to review code for. And, you know, another one of these could be the quality of code. So you can automate some of that stuff, but some of it, you know, you want humans to take a look at the code and say, all right, I'm going to perhaps assume that the code is doing what's advertised, right? But is it good enough? Is it maintainable? Is it something we want in our code base? And that's, you know, another great motivation to have a code review. And there's so many different things, you know, is it secure? Are there any performance implications to what's happening there? So many different things that
是你想要去测试和审查的。而寻找Bug，就像我说的，在我看来是动机中最不重要的一项。但是，好吧，假设你已经确定了代码审查的动机是什么。正如我刚才所说的那样，它在各个团队之间甚至在同一家公司内部都不必保持一致。所以在WeWork，举个例子，我们有一个计费团队。他们正在构建一个向客户收费的产品。当你向客户收费时，你需要确保一切都超级准确。你需要确保一切都符合税法，等等，等等。代码审查过程其实非常漫长。其中一部分甚至受到监管。
you would like to test and review. And finding bugs, like I said, to me is way towards the bottom of the motivation. But, you know, let's say that you've decided what your motivation for code reviews is. As I said earlier, it doesn't have to be consistent between teams, even with the same company. So at WeWork, for example, we had a billing team. They were building a product that build our customers. And when you build your customers, you need to make sure that everything is super accurate. And you need to make sure that everything complies with tax laws, etc, etc. And the code review process is actually very long. And some of it is actually regulated.
你必须确保为了满足某些类型的合规规则，审查需要通过某些流程，等等，等等。但随后你可能还有另一个团队，他们致力于面向公众的网站，希望快速迭代并将实验推向市场。如果发生任何糟糕的事情，他们只需向前滚动并即兴修复即可。为什么这两个团队要遵循相同的流程呢？他们出发时的动机就不同。关于如何进行代码审查的最佳实践的博客文章中所写的内容，不可能同等地适用于这两个团队，对吧？我的意思是，必须针对你们团队的具体动机进行某种调整。是的，也许这个比喻不太恰当，但前几天有人提起了一件事，我觉得它适用于这里或类似的情况，
You have to make sure that to meet certain types of certain sets of compliance rules, the review needs to go through some process, etc, etc. But then you have another team that might be working on the front-facing website and wants to iterate quickly and get experiments out there. And if anything bad happened, they're just going to roll forward and fix it on the go. Why would those two teams follow the same process? They start with different motivations. It can't be that, you know, what I'm seeing in a blog post about the best way to do code reviews applies to both of these teams equally, right? I mean, there has to be some sort of adaptation to the specific motivations you have on your team. Yeah, maybe a poor analogy, but someone brought something up the other day that I think like applies here or whatever,
那就是，如果你找一些跟木头打交道的人——一个搭建房屋木框架的人和一个制作高级家具的人——他们可能都会用锤子，也可能都会用锯子，但他们使用的目的并不完全相同。当然，都是为了切木头或钉钉子，但如果你在制作高级家具，你需要施加的精细度和力度，与把783根两英寸乘四英寸的木方钉在一起以建造房屋的人是非常不同的，
that if you take folks who work with wood wood someone who like frames a home and someone who builds fine furniture they may both use a hammer they may both use a saw but like they don't use them for the same purpose like sure to cut wood or nail a nail but like if you're doing fine furniture like the delicacy and like force you're going to apply are very different than someone who has 783 two by fours to put together to, you know, make your house like the, how,
怎么说呢，如果你敲砸时失误了会怎么样？对吧？“哦，我敲到了那个木方上。谁在乎呢？它会被遮盖掉的，
how, what happens if you miss, right? Like, Oh, I hit the two by four. Who cares? It's going to get covered up,
你知道的。”而相比之下，如果是“我正在把这枚钉子钉进这个价值一千美元的木块里”或者别的什么，对吧？你可能会说：“哦，他们都在敲锤子。
you know, versus like I'm driving in this nail into this, you know, a thousand dollar piece of wood or whatever, right? Like you may both say, Oh, they're both hammering.
他们都在做木工活。”我不知道这个词用得对不对，他们都在进行木工制作。但按照你的说法，其动机完全不同。而且你评价他们表现的方式也不应该是一样的。是的，你说得完全对。你知道吗，这 tatsächlich (德语：确实) 发生在我身上过，当时我把这个设计展示给一个制作家具的木匠时，他看了一眼便说道：“这看起来像是造房子的人设计的。这根本不是你设计家具或组装家具的方式。”所以，你知道，他对连接木块的方式是“由内而外”还是“由外而内”颇有微词。所以你说得完全对，我曾亲眼目睹过这一点。
They're both doing carpentry or I don't know if that's the right word for it. They're both doing woodworking. But to your thing, the motivations are entirely different. And the way you would judge their performance shouldn't be the same. Yeah, you're absolutely right. And you know what, this actually happened to me when I showed this design to a carpenter that's doing furniture and he looked at it and he said, this looks like someone who's building homes designed this. This is not the way that you would design a piece of furniture and not the way you'd assemble it. So, you know, he had a beef with the inside out versus outside in of like connecting, you know, the pieces of wood together. So you're absolutely right. And I've seen it firsthand.
我想把话题拉回来，我的意思是，你的说明也许人们并没有意识到，实际上针对医疗或其他领域的安全或隐私，存在着某些认证或标准，在这些领域中，制成品、代码审查本身变成了一件需要被记录和处理的事情，以便日后用于审计目的。这并不是说外部审计员会查看你所有的代码审查，而是他们希望能够抽查其中之一。他们希望看到审查是一直在进行的，而且不是盖橡皮图章走过场，对吧？他们希望看到其中投入了思考，花去了时间。这与你刚才提到的那种情况截然不同，比如“嘿，我必须在37秒内将这个热修复推送到服务器上，否则我们在某某地方就要损失一百万美元了”，对吧？这两件事不应该遵循同一种代码审查方式。是的，我见过审计员抽查代码
And I think like to bring it back, I mean, I think your illustration, maybe people don't realize that actually that there are certain accreditations or sort of standards of safety or privacy for things like medical or whatever, where actually the artifacts, the code review itself becomes like a thing that should be recorded and processed to be followed for auditing purposes later. It's not that an external auditor is going to look at every one of your code reviews, but they want to be able to look at one of them. And they want to see that it's always done and that it's not rubber stamped, right? That thought is put into it, that time is taken. And that's very different than like you mentioned, you know, hey, I got to get this hot fix out to the server in 37 seconds, or we're going to lose a million dollars on the, you know, whatever, right? Like, those two things don't have, shouldn't follow the same sort of code review. Yeah, I've seen auditors, you know, sample code
审查并进行查看。如果你看这样的代码审查，如果其中某个字段缺失了——我们对你们的代码审查进行抽查。我们遇到过这种情况。我见过。当这种情况发生时，你真的要确保代码审查做到滴水不漏，如果这些审查有特定的结构，则不能有任何缺失的字段，等等。但如果你只想“快速行动并打破常规”，那么潜在地你可能会
reviews and look at them. And if you look at a code review like that, if one of the fields is missing, there's a sample through your code reviews. We've had that. I've seen that. And when that happens, you really want to make sure that the code review, everyone's dotted their I's and crossed their T's, and there's no missing field if there is a specific structure to those reviews, etc. But then if all you want to do is move fast and break things, potentially you could be
跳过某些环节。也许这个在我们的代码审查中据称是强制性的东西，如果我们认为有充分的理由，其实偶尔放弃它也是可以接受的。所以宽容的程度也可以根据审查的动力来源而改变。是的，所以我觉得这些点拨太棒了，对吧？比如，不仅仅是修复Bug，还要把它用在手头正确的任务上？它是严格的合规审计并且有非常具体的格式，还是更偏向于超级快速，亦或是介于两者之间？
skipping some of the things. And maybe this thing that is supposedly mandatory on our code reviews, we're actually fine with dropping it every now and then if we think like there's good justification. So the level of leniency could also change according to what's the impetus for the review. Yeah, so I think these callouts are awesome, right? Like, you know, not only about fixing bugs, about using it for the right sort of task at hand? Like, is it rigorous audit compliance and has like a very specific format or is it more sort of go super fast or is it a kind of middle of the road?
我猜大多数任务可能都属于那种中庸的类型，并且要确保代码审查的所有正确要素和活动部件都已到位，而且就像你说的，我认为这是一个很棒的点拨。这倒算不上我的一个“死穴”或者说强迫症，但也是我经常做的一件事，听起来可能有点傻，我筛选的一个东西——我们使用C++，我会筛选那些使用——我不会说被禁用的C++部分，但就是把C++玩得太花哨的人——而我会以一个经验更丰富的人的身份介入，
I assume most tasks are probably kind of the middle of the road ones and sort of making sure that all of the right bits and moving parts are in place for for code review and sort of like you said i think there was a great call out it's a i don't say a pet peeve of mine but something i also do so like it kind of sounds dumb one thing i screen for like we use c++ and i screen for people using like i don't say banned parts of c++ but like getting too juicy with their c++ work and i'll come in as sort of like, you know, having been around a
然后说：“不，实际上，为了可维护性起见，请不要搞这种巧妙而诡异的模板元编程把戏，直接把它写出来吧。”所以为了这个目的去做这件事听起来可能有点傻里傻气的。但这是为了确保风格——而不是linter（代码检查工具）的风格，就像你刚才暗示的那些用来检查代码编译和代码风格的工具一样。我们没说那些，但我会提到。所以，你知道，可以说，对我来说这是更高级别的、属于人类审美选择的东西。比如，你如何选择分解你的函数？你如何以可读的方式组织你的代码？你在这里应用了什么范式？这就是我在进行审查时部分所
bit longer and sort of say like, no, actually, like for maintainability purposes, please, like, don't do this clever, weird template metaprogramming trip and just like, you know, write it out. And so it sounds kind of goofy to kind of do for that purpose. But it's about making sure that the style and not the linter style, like you were alluding to other tools to do the job of checking that code compiles, linting. We didn't say those, but I'll. And so, you know, sort of saying or sort of saying that, like, for me, it's a higher level stuff that is a human stylistic choice. Like, how are you choosing to decompose your functions? How are you, you know, structuring your code in a readable way? What paradigm are you applying here? And that's what I'm sort of
寻找的东西。是的，归根结底，你知道，我们阅读代码的时间比编写代码的时间要多得多。毫无疑问，阅读代码是一项比编写代码更重要的技能。你会在审查中用到它，对吧？当你阅读那段代码时，你需要确保其他人也能读懂它。你刚才关于那些C++小花招的说法很棒，因为在许多情况下，你确实可以阅读这段代码并在电光石石间明白它在做什么，但你知道其他看它的人会觉得很艰难、会与之挣扎。所以有时你不得不站在那些不一定和你具有相同经验水平的人的角度来看待它。当我提到经验水平时，你知道，
looking for, in part when I do my reviews. Yeah, eventually, you know, we, we spend more time reading code than writing it. And definitely reading code is a more important skill than writing code. And you get to use it in a review, right? And when you read that code, you need to make sure that others can read that code too. And what you said about those C++ tricks is great because, you know, in many cases, you can actually read that code and understand what it's doing and, you know, in a split second, but you know that other people looking at it are going to have a hard time and are going to struggle with it. So sometimes you have to kind of look at it from the point of view of someone who's, you know, not necessarily at the same experience level as you. And when I say experience level, you know,
这可能不仅仅是指一般意义上的经验水平，而是对特定产品或特定代码库的经验。是的，我想补充另一个我最近遇到的情况——正当我们在这个话题附近讨论时，也许人们会争论，让我们看看你的观点如何，它究竟属于代码审查还是其他环节——
this could be, you know, not just an experience level, generally speaking, but experience with a specific product or a specific code base. Yeah, I think another one, just to chime in while we're in this vicinity that I've done recently is, and maybe people could debate, oh, let's see what your opinion is, if it belongs in the code review or in something else,
那就是有人做了一个抉择，而我向他们提出了质疑，比如：“嘿，代码库里有两种实现这个的方法，你看，比如A方法或B方法。
which is someone sort of made a choice that was a choice, and I sort of put to them, like, hey, we have two ways in the code base of doing this, like, you know, this way of made a choice that was a choice. And I sort of put to them like, hey, we have two ways in the code base of doing this, like, you know, this way A or way B. And we used to use only way A, we've started introducing way B, you're writing this utility, and this sort of like, like, what, what is your decision mechanism that you're choosing here to do way A, instead of moving it to new to new way to way B. And then we sort of had a little bit of a discussion where other people could kind of chime in, which is, hey, we're writing this code. We're trying
我们以前只用A方法，现在我们开始引入B方法了，而你正在编写这个工具函数，你在这里选择使用A方法而不是迁移到新方法、使用B方法，你的决策机制是什么？”然后我们进行了一番讨论，其他人也纷纷加入进来，大意是：“嘿，我们正在编写这段代码，我们正试图转向一种新方法。我们用来决定使用哪种技术或在哪种场景下使用的准则是什么？”我其实并不清楚这是否适合出现在代码审查中。我的意思是，我在代码审查里这么做了。也许我该感到羞愧。但是，如果你要因此而烧死我——不过，我觉得，对我来说这是一个有趣的现象，它之所以说得通，是因为它发生在正在发生问题的地方。但我其实并不清楚这是否——团队中的每个人都看得到吗？这是做这件事的正确地方吗？所以我觉得，一旦你遇到了一种你认为不再是该团队推荐实践的做法，那么在审查过程中把它指出来绝对
to move to a new way. What is the rubric we're using to follow about how to decide what technology to use or which place? And I don't know, actually, if that's appropriate for a coder. I mean, I did it in a code review. Shame on me, maybe. But, like, if you're going to burn me for it. But, like, I think, like, to me, that was an interesting, like, it made sense because it was in the place where it was happening. But I'm actually, like, unclear if that's a – does everybody see that on the team? Like, is it the right place to do it? it. So I think that, you know, once you've encountered a practice that you think is no longer the recommended practice for that team, then calling it out during the review definitely
是非常合乎情理的。但根据这两种做法之间的差异有多大，可能会暗示这样一个事实：这件事本应该更早地进行讨论，也许是通过相同的形式，也许是通过不同的形式。但如果不同的做法是——当我们对计数器进行自增时，我们不再使用 `I++`，而是使用 `++I`——在审查中指出这一点是可以的，这没问题。但如果新的做法是：“哦，顺便说一句，我们不再使用远程RPC了，
makes a lot of sense. But depending on how big the change is between those two ways of doing that could hint at, you know, the fact that it should have been discussed earlier, perhaps in the same form, perhaps in a different form. But if the different way is we're no longer doing I++, we're doing plus plus I, when we're incrementing a counter, that's fine to do in a review, that's okay. But if the new way is, oh, by the way, we're no longer using remote RPC.
我们正在使用RESTful端点。”也许这就太晚了。这是一个很棒的——我不想说这是一个短语，但它几乎可以印在T恤上，也许不能。但代码审查有时就是太迟了。我认为这是某种张力所在：一方面有人没有足够早地让大家了解一个具争议性的决定，另一方面却在代码审查时才让大家知道，迫使他们承担超出合理范围的工作，而此时他们原本已经做好了预算并认为时间已经截止了，
We're using RESTful endpoints. Maybe that's too late. That's a great, like, I don't want to say phrase, like almost fits on a T-shirt, maybe not. But like code review sometimes is too late. And I think this is like a piece of tension between someone not letting people know soon enough about a controversial decision, letting it people in code review and forcing them to really take on more work than is appropriate when they had budgeted and they thought time was done. And
现在他们却要面对一个巨大的改动。当你这么说的时候，这里有一个重要观点需要讨论。代码审查可能是结合软技能与硬技能最常见、有时也是最好的例子之一。所以代码审查不仅仅关乎代码。它是人与人之间实际互动的过程。就像你说的，有时人们在审查时可能会挑刺找茬，或者试图瞒过审查者。但这仅仅是
now they're faced with a large change. And when you say that, there's an important point to be discussed here. Code reviews are probably one of the most common and sometimes one of the best examples of combining soft and hard skills. So a code review is not just about code. It's an actual process between humans. And like you said, sometimes people might be looking, might be out to get someone else in a review or might be trying to slip something past the reviewer. But these are just, you know, two things you might find. But
你可能会发现的两种情况而已。人类行为还有许多其他的模式可以在审查中找到，正因如此，代码审查可能会变得极具争议。这就是那些通常自我意识很强、有时又有着利益冲突的开发人员登场并不得不设法解决问题的地方。这里有很多反模式滋生的空间。你提到的那两种只是其中两个例子。当你仔细想想时，这真的很吓人。是的，我认为我尝试过的一件事——我不会说我去推广它，但我尝试鼓励人们去做的一件事，我想你之前也部分暗示过这一点——人们会去想代码审查这个工具，不管是GitHub还是其他什么工具，不管你用什么代码审查工具，都要根据需求对它进行定制。但我还是要对审查者说，审查其实也可以随时发生。
there are so many other patterns of human behavior that you can find in reviews and reviews could be very contentious because of that. You know, that's where developers who in many cases have large egos come in and sometimes have conflicting interests and have to sort it out somehow. There's room for a lot of anti-patterns in here. The two that you mentioned are just two examples. There are so many others. It's scary when you think about it. Yeah think one thing i've tried to i don't say promote i've tried to encourage people is and i think you were alluding to this early on in in part which people think about the tool of code review whether it's like github or some other whatever tool you use code review um and that tailoring it to the needs. But I would say to the review can happen as well.
你不需要把每一次审查都做得独一无二，但对于某些改动，我会告诉人们：“听着，在你把代码提出来进行代码审查之前，你需要先跟团队通气。你需要去跟别人聊聊，或者走到某人的办公桌前，或者安排一次视频会议，花点时间带他们过一遍代码，这样他们在进行审查时才会感到舒适，才能理解正在发生什么，这并不是说
You don't want to tailor every review in a specific way, but there are some changes which I will tell people, look, you need to socialize this before you put it up for code review. You need to go talk, actually go to someone's desk or schedule a video conference call with them and have a time to walk through so that they feel comfortable in doing the review that they understand what's happening it's not that
这个改动本身是不可避免的或糟糕的，它可能就得是那个样子，这是一个巨大的改动，但要提前给人们打个招呼。”这本身仍然属于代码审查——你在审查代码，但你没有使用代码审查工具。你把代码审查的“做什么”和“为什么”拆分成了不同的部分。你可能仍然会经历让某人批准它的正式流程，但它可能是一个相对“空洞”的、需要做出的请求或修改量很少的流程。为什么？因为你把工作做在了前面，因为你让别人过目了。这里我要点名批评的一种现象是：人们喜欢对实习生这么干——等到实习生快要结束实习时，让他们提交一大堆代码，然后像批改红头文件一样把代码批得面目全非，因为他们
that change is necessarily avoidable or bad it may just need to be that way it's a massive change but give people a heads up and and that that in itself is still code review like you are reviewing that code but you're not using the code review tool right like you're splitting the the sort of what the why of code review into different parts you might still go through the formal process of having someone approve it but it might be a relatively empty you know amount of requests or changes to be made why because you did them up front because you had someone go through it and the like one i'll call out here is like people like to do that with interns like wait till an intern gets almost to the end of the internship have them drop off a bunch of code and then like red mark the heck out of it because they didn't
并不知道这就是团队的风格或规矩。而我认为：“不，这真是一个——正如你所说的那种软技能——这真是一个糟糕的软技能实践。这真的非常令人沮丧。”第二点是，你其实早就知道会发生这种情况，却任由事情发展到那一步。你本应该直接走到他们面前说：“嘿，我们能坐下来看看你的代码吗？你能把你的分支推上去让我看看吗？”无论你想用什么正确的技术，你都要为人们的审查成功做好铺垫。而且，你知道的，如果人们在实习的最后一天或最后一周才进入代码审查阶段，并且所有东西都被打上红叉，那么，从某种意义上说，这就像是一种瀑布流开发方法，对吧？你让他们
know this is the style or this is the whatever and i'm like no that's a really like you said soft skill that's a really bad soft skill practice like it's really frustrating and the second thing is like you really you you probably knew in advance that was going to happen and you let it get that far like you should have just gone to them and said hey can we sit down and look at your code can you put up your branch and let me look at it whatever the right you know technology you want to set people up for success with their reviews and and you know if people are getting to the review in their last day or last week of the internship and everything is red marked, then, you know, in a way that's sort of a waterfall approach, right? You let them
提前把所有代码都写好，然后才进入审查阶段，一切都在那里集中爆发。之后它才会进入下一个阶段，这非常瀑布流。而且，你知道，如今瀑布流被认为是一种不好的做法，这有充分的理由。但这并不意味着你不应该在编写代码之前讨论事情。这并不意味着每一次改动都是一样的，而且改动的规模很重要，它产生的影响则更加重要。更重要的是，正如你所说，人们的动机或他们成功将代码推送到生产环境的愿望也在其中发挥了一定作用。我想我们可以就代码审查滔滔不绝地讲很长时间，发表高论或夸夸其谈，但我试着着陆，
write everything in advance and then it goes to the review stage where everything is happening. And then afterwards it's going to go to the next stage that it's very waterfall. And, you know, waterfall is considered, you know, bad practice these days, and for good reasons. But it doesn't mean that you shouldn't be discussing things before you write them. It doesn't mean that every change is the same. And, you know, the size of the change matters, the impact that it has matters even more. And more importantly, like you said, the motivation that people might have or their desire to succeed in getting their code into production also plays a part in that. I think we could probably go at length for code reviews and, and pontificating or soapboxing, but I'll try to land,
让我们试着把这架飞机降落下来。也就是说，正如你所提到的，我们甚至还没有——或者我想我提了，
let's try to try to try to land this, this aircraft down, which is, I think, as you mentioned, like the, we haven't even, or I guess I did,
你没提，但你知道的——我们没有讨论具体的工具或代码审查的“如何做”。相反，我们探讨了“为什么”这个话题。我知道你可能还有满肚子的话想说，但还有没有什么是我们没来得及涉及的，或者你想拿出来强调一下的呢？嗯，你知道的，就仅仅是这样一个事实：这是人与人之间的互动，你需要注意自己的行为举止，就像在任何其他社交场合一样。人们往往会认为我在代码审查中写的东西不像是一场正常的对话。我可以尖酸刻薄，我可以冒犯别人，我可以当一个糟糕的同事。嗯，猜怎么着？你不能。这是另一种形式的沟通。你需要保持尊重。为了他们所做的事情，人们付出了艰辛的努力。即使你不同意，即使你是对的，那也可能是因为对方习惯了以不同方式运作的不同团队。对于他们习惯的语境来说，他们可能是对的。你绝对应该假设他们不是故意要做任何坏事的。所以，代码审查大概是让开发者们怒目相向的最快捷径了。
you didn't, but you know, we haven't talked about the specific tool or the how of code review. Instead, we sort of explored this topic of, of why I know there's probably tons more you'd like to say, but any sort of like final things we kind of didn't get to or sort of things you want to call out? Well, you know, just the fact that it is an interaction between
所以请记住这一点，行事要小心。是的，太棒的观察了。我的意思是，套用你刚才的妙语，对于面试官问什么是上下文切换，就像是：你是认真的吗？这不是一个恰当的代码审查意见。像“你是认真的吗？”这种话——我见过达到这种程度的言论，这可不是——比如去找他们，给他们发个Slack消息，安排个会议——你完全可以这样做，这并没有违反什么
humans and you need to be careful in how you conduct yourself, just like any other way. You know, people tend to think that what I write in a code review is not like a regular conversation. I can be snarky. I can be offensive. I can just be a bad colleague. Well, guess what? You can't. It's another form of communication. You need to be respectful. People have worked hard to do what they do. And even if you don't agree with it, and even if you're right, it could be because the other person is used to a different team that was working in a different way. And they could be right for the context that they're used to. And you definitely should assume that they're not doing anything bad on purpose. So just code reviews are probably the easiest way to get to developers at each other's throats.
不可侵犯的契约，比如他们撤下代码审查、修改了某些东西然后再放回去——这完全没问题。所以你是对的。我见过太多人因为别人吹毛求疵而怒目相向。这里有一种文化规范需要建立和塑造。我们所有人，每次这样做的时候，都在潜移默化地影响团队的代码审查文化。特别是新人，必须让他们融入这个流程。别误会我。我也在代码审查中经历过属于我自己的争论，我并不完美。我也犯过许多我试图告诫别人不要去犯的错误。但随着你做得越来越多，你开始在对话走向错误方向之前就提前看出这些模式。
So just keep that in mind and be careful. Yeah, such a great observation. I mean, I guess to use your sort of quip from earlier to your interviewer asking about what's a context switch. Like, are you serious? Not an appropriate code review comment. Like, are you serious? Like, I have seen stuff at that level that's not a a sort of like a like go to them like send them a slack message schedule a meeting like you can have it's not some violation of some
所以请记住这一点，并且要小心。是的，这是一个非常棒的观察。我的意思是，我想借用你之前的那种俏皮话来回答面试官关于什么是上下文切换的问题。比如，你是认真的吗？这不是一个合适的代码审查评论。比如，你是认真的吗？我见过那种水平的东西，那不是那种……比如直接去找他们，发个Slack消息，安排个会议，你可以……这并不是违反了某种
inviolate like contract that they pull down the code review change something and put it back up like this is perfectly fine uh and so you're right. I have seen way too many people get at each other's throats because someone was grinding. There's a cultural norm to establish and help shape. All of us, every time we do it, are subtly influencing the team's culture of code review. And new people especially have to get onboarded to that process. And don't get me wrong. I've had my fair share of arguments over code reviews and I'm not perfect. And I've made many of the mistakes that I try to preach other people not to do. But as you do more and more of these, you start seeing the patterns in advance of a conversation not going the right way.
神圣不可侵犯的契约，以至于他们需要撤下代码审查、修改点什么再重新放上去——这完全没问题。所以你是对的。我见过太多人因为别人在拼命而吵得不可开交。我们需要建立并塑造一种文化规范。我们每个人在每次这样做的时候，都在潜移默化地影响着团队的代码审查文化。特别是新人，必须融入这个流程。别误会我。我也曾为代码审查争论过不少次，我也不是完美的。我犯过许多我试图告诫别人不要犯的错误。但随着你做得越来越多，你会开始在对话走向错误方向之前提前看到这些模式。
And if you're the more senior of the people interacting in that review, that is your responsibility at this point to figure out that the conversation is not going in a productive direction. And that is perhaps the time for you to maybe take it to a different medium where you can discuss privately and reach some understanding and then come back to the public conversation in a better mood and less argumentatively. Is that a word? Argumentative. Argumentative. Yeah.
如果你是这次评审中资历较深的人，在这个时候，你的责任就是意识到对话没有朝着富有成效的方向发展。也许此时正是你将对话转移到另一个媒介的时候，在那里你可以私下讨论并达成某种共识，然后以更好的心情、少一点争论的方式回到公开对话中。这是一个词吗？争论性的。争论性的。是的。
Yeah, that's, that's such a such a good point. I mean, I think the one thing I tell senior folks is, you know, if there's two junior folks, or more junior folks, you know, arguing about something like they're sort of in a competition in a sense. And you as a, you know, you know, a staff engineer or a principal engineer, like you've already won in the sense, like you've already gotten the thing that these people want to have one day. And so, you know, taking that approach of saying, look, you know, you've, you've already won and you can't, you can't unwin. Like no one's going to down. I mean, I've never heard of a company down leveling a prince, an engineer. I mean, they'll, they'll fire people before they down level them. So, so it's like, you, you've kind of, you've established yourself, you know,
是的，这是一个非常非常好的观点。我的意思是，我认为我告诉资深员工的一点是，你知道，如果有两个初级员工，或者资历较浅的员工，在为某事争论，他们某种程度上就像是在参加比赛。而你作为一个，你知道，资深工程师或首席工程师，从某种意义上说你已经赢了——你已经得到了这些人有一天想要拥有的东西。所以，你知道，采取这种态度，说：“看，你知道，你已经赢了，而且你无法‘取消赢’。”就像没有人会被降级一样。我的意思是，我从未听说过公司对首席工程师进行降级。我的意思是，他们在降级之前就会解雇员工。所以，这就好比，你已经确立了自己的地位，你知道，
and so now like, if you can make a small sacrifice to really like bring these people together that's that's really something that you're uniquely kind of positioned to do and that's something that i think is is could be difficult for people as they kind of move up to uh to understand that that is something that they're uniquely positioned to be able to provide to the to the company but eventually that that is something that they're uniquely positioned to be able to provide to the company. But eventually that's what their job is, right? If you're a staff engineer, one of the responsibilities that you have is making everyone around you better, all the other engineers. So if they don't understand that, maybe they should be down-leveled. I have read a lot of articles on hacker news about what makes a senior
所以现在，如果你能做出一点牺牲，真正把这些人聚在一起，这确实是你处于独特地位能够做到的事情。我认为随着人们不断晋升，理解这一点可能会很困难，即这是他们能够为公司提供的独特价值。但最终，这就是他们的工作，对吧？如果你是一名资深工程师，你的职责之一就是让你周围的每个人变得更好，所有的其他工程师。所以如果他们不明白这一点，也许他们应该被降级。我在 Hacker News 上读过很多关于是什么造就了一位资深
engineer i don't recall reading a lot about empathy or sacrifice or what are you guys talking about that's how it makes a senior engineer you know it's just like the college thing right they teach you the wrong things all the people who chose spaces became senior that's how i have to admit though jason jason i'm i'm i'm envious every time you speak you have such a good microphone and you know i i'm on my you know crappy headset patrick and i got when did we get microphones like five six years in i don't even know how that happened and then i reverted back from, I'm too lazy. Well, yes, you moved, right?
工程师的文章，我不记得读到过很多关于同理心、牺牲的内容，或者你们在谈论什么？这就是造就资深工程师的方式，你知道，这就像大学里学的那样，对吧？他们教给你错误的东西。所有选择空格（spaces）缩进的人都成了资深人士，就是这样。不过我必须承认，杰森，杰森，我真的很羡慕，每次你说话时，你都有这么好的麦克风，而我用的则是帕特里克和我弄来的那种糟糕的耳机。我们是什么时候买麦克风的？大概五六年以后吧？我甚至不知道这是怎么发生的，然后我又换回来了，因为我太懒了。好吧，是的，你搬过家，对吧？
It's probably still on the box somewhere. Somewhere, I got to dig it up. All right. Well, that has been an awesome exploration. I know there's more to do, but I'm just going to, I'm going to just put the sort of period at the end of that sentence, whether we punctuate, whether we should have or not. But let's talk a bit about, about Woco. So we sort of put a pin in it in the beginning. We're coming back to it now. You saw a need for a startup, right? I mean, like, ultimately, maybe I'm
它可能还在某个盒子里。总得把它翻出来。好吧，这是一次精彩的探索。我知道还有更多的工作要做，但我只是打算，我打算在那句话的末尾画上一个句号，不管我们该不该加标点符号。但让我们来聊聊 Woco。我们在开始时暂且搁置了这个话题，现在我们回过头来谈谈。你看到了一个创业的需求，对吧？我的意思是，最终，也许我是在
presuming that's what founders tell us, right? Like, I saw a need. I saw something that was not there. And I was uniquely suited or so passionate that I needed to go build it. Help tell us, like, why Wilco? Yeah, sure. So you know, if you take a lot of the points that we discussed today, you realize that there is a mismatch between what people learn, and what people are actually doing as software developers. And it doesn't matter what level I mean, like you said, you read all these, these articles on what a senior engineer should be. And most of it is about code. But code is just one skill out of many that a good software engineer needs. And college doesn't teach them
假设这就是创始人告诉我们的，对吧？比如，我看到了一个需求。我看到了一些原本不存在的东西。我是最合适的人选，或者充满激情，以至于我必须去打造它。跟我们讲讲，为什么是 Wilco？好的，没问题。所以，你知道，如果你把我们今天讨论的很多观点结合起来，你就会意识到人们学到的东西与软件开发人员实际在做的事情之间存在脱节。不管是什么级别，我的意思是，就像你说的，你阅读了所有关于资深工程师应该具备哪些素质的文章。其中大部分都与代码有关。但代码只是优秀软件工程师所需众多技能中的一项，而大学并没有教给他们
that boot camps don't teach them that. And eventually developers need to practice. And the only way to practice is on the job. But when you practice on the job, it's A, very slow. It's B, very error prone. And C, it doesn't provide equal opportunity. So much depends on which team you get to and whether you had the opportunity to get into a good team. So what we said is,
这一点，训练营也没有教给他们这一点。最终开发人员需要练习，而唯一的练习方式就是在工作中。但是当你在工作中练习时，A，速度非常慢；B，极易出错；C，它无法提供平等的机遇。很大程度上取决于你进入了哪个团队，以及你是否有机会进入一个好的团队。所以我们当时想的是：
what if we give developers a good way to practice? And when we say practice, we mean all of the skills, not just code writing. What if we give developers a good way to practice that is safe, that is all of the skills, not just code writing. What if we give developers a good way to practice that is safe, that is in their own pace, that depends just on their merit. And we came upon this idea of giving them or letting them join a fantasy company. And that company has a production-like system with logging and monitoring and analytics and
如果我们为开发人员提供一种良好的练习方式会怎样？当我们说练习时，我们指的是所有的技能，而不仅仅是写代码。如果我们为开发人员提供一种安全、能够按照他们自己的节奏、完全取决于他们自身能力的练习方式会怎样？我们想到了这个主意：让他们加入一家虚拟公司。这家公司拥有生产环境般的系统，包括日志、监控、分析、
load balancing and a real data set, not just five records in a single table. And it has the biggest mess of all, which is people. So you have colleagues and you have team leads and product managers and stakeholders and all of that. And on top of that, you start going on simulations or adventures, or we call them quests because we're so influenced by 80s video games. So you start going on quests and a quest could be, we have a performance problem in production. Please figure out what happened. What's the root cause? What's the extent of the damage? Fix it and communicate it to stakeholders. And the focus is not on fix it because you can learn how to fix it in college or at a
负载均衡和一个真实的数据集，而不仅仅是一个单表里的五条记录。它拥有最复杂的问题——人。所以你有同事、团队主管、产品经理、利益相关者以及所有这些角色。在此之上，你开始进行模拟或冒险，或者我们称之为任务（quests），因为我们深受80年代电子游戏的影响。所以你开始执行任务，一个任务可能是：我们的生产环境遇到了性能问题，请找出发生了什么，根本原因是什么，损害程度有多大，修复它并将其传达给利益相关者。重点不在于修复它，因为你可以在大学、
boot camp or even online. The focus is, how do you even know that something's wrong? What do you do to investigate it? When do you go for a quick and dirty fix? When do you go for something more meaningful? How do you ensure that lessons are learned and implemented? And that's definitely something that's not covered anywhere. And all of these tiny things that you really only pick up on the job.
训练营甚至在线上学习如何修复。重点是：你怎么知道出问题了？你采取什么措施来调查？什么时候该采用快速且凑合的修复方案？什么时候该采用更有意义的方案？你如何确保吸取教训并加以落实？这绝对是任何地方都没有涵盖的内容，所有这些小细节你真的只能在工作中领悟到。
And that's what we're trying to help you do with Wilco. Yeah, I mean, this is, you're right, like such an uncovered, people make quips about sometimes, like maybe I only wrote one line of code, but the hard part is figuring out what line of code to write and i think yeah once you know what it is you're trying to do i mean we make that choice just stack overflow or whatever right like you just go to stack overflow like how to turn off you know database backups and you know during peak performance
这就是我们试图通过 Wilco 来帮助你做的事情。是的，我的意思是，你是对的，这是一个未被填补的空白。人们有时会开玩笑说，也许我只写了一行代码，但困难的部分在于弄清楚该写哪一行代码。我想是的，一旦你知道了你想做什么，我的意思是，我们会做出这样的选择——去 Stack Overflow 或其他地方，对吧？就像你直接去 Stack Overflow 搜索：如何在峰值性能期间关闭数据库备份
or whatever i don't making something up but knowing what to google this is sort of this like untaught very long lead time long iteration or even knowing that you should google oh there you go fair enough like i mean let's say i change the database schema it's no longer the same should i do something about it or should should I just, you know, go to production and everything would be okay? Well, turns out, most people early in their career are probably not going to search anything about it, they're going to assume that, oh, I just added an index, everything is, you know, everything should be fine. But then it goes to production and the database is halting and, and, you know, nothing's working. Well, you should have Googled it before, and now it's kind of too late. So it's not just how to Google, it's even when.
或者类似的东西——我这是瞎编的。但知道该去谷歌搜索什么，这是一种未曾教导过、反馈周期极长的技能，甚至连“你应该去谷歌搜索”这一点都不知道。哦，对了，说得对！比如说，我修改了数据库模式，它不再是原来的样子了，我应该为此做点什么，还是直接发布到生产环境，一切都会没事的？好吧，事实证明，职业生涯早期的大多数人可能不会去搜索任何相关信息，他们会认为：“哦，我只是加了一个索引，一切都应该没问题的。”但随后它上了生产环境，数据库挂了，而且，你知道，什么都不工作了。好吧，你本来应该事先去谷歌搜索的，现在已经有点太迟了。所以这不仅仅是如何去谷歌搜索，甚至还包括什么时候去搜索。
Yeah. This too, we were joking about senior engineers, this on-the-job, hard-knock training about building up that intuition a bit. And it's great to hear that. I think maybe I call it intuition, but actually, you're kind of like, no, no, no, wait, wait, this isn't that this is some unteachable, unknowable thing that actually put into the right circumstances. There are some commonalities here, some, some simulations where we can put people through and sort of have them
是的。这也是我们之前开玩笑讨论资深工程师时提到的：这种在工作中饱经锤炼的培训，有助于建立这种直觉。很高兴听到这些。我想也许我称之为直觉，但实际上，你会觉得：不，不，不，等等，这不是什么无法教导、不可知的东西，只要置身于正确的环境中，这里面其实有一些共性，有一些模拟，我们可以让人们经历这些，并让他们
kind of realize that themselves. Yeah. I mean, like they say, the way to Carnegie Hall is practice, practice, practice, right? So it's not just for music. It goes like that for every type of profession. And software engineering is no different. You need to practice. And practicing actually allows you to develop intuition. Musicians that improvise practice a lot beforehand. It's not just that, you know, they go out and improvise, they learn the basics, understand what are scales and how they fit with each other and how melody and harmony work together. And then they can start improvising, right? And same goes for software engineering if you practice enough you'll develop that intuition that allows you to do things or know uh when things might go wrong and when things uh are are pretty
自己意识到这一点。是的。正如他们所说，通往卡耐基音乐厅的方法就是练习，练习，再练习，对吧？所以这不仅适用于音乐，每一种职业都是如此。软件工程也不例外，你需要练习。练习实际上能让你培养直觉。会即兴演奏的音乐家事先会进行大量的练习。不仅仅是他们直接上台即兴发挥，他们学习基础知识，了解什么是音阶、它们如何契合以及旋律与和声如何协同工作。然后他们才能开始即兴创作，对吧？软件工程也是一样，如果你练习得足够多，你就会培养出那种直觉，让你能够做成事情，或者知道什么时候事情可能会出错，什么时候事情
safe you might still get it wrong but at least in most cases uh you'll get it right and you know we've actually seen other professions do something similar So one of the things we looked at as we were working on Wilco is this thing called CTA, which is cognitive task analysis. And what we've seen is that firefighters learn the theory of fires and what to do in an incident, but then they go to an incident and they might not necessarily be able to apply the theory that they've learned, whereas a firefighter with 20 years of experience gets into a scene and knows exactly what to do and how to do it, but they can't teach it. And what CTA does is it tries to extract that knowledge, that expert knowledge,
相当安全。你可能还是会弄错，但在大多数情况下，你会做对。你知道，我们实际上看到其他行业也在做类似的事情。因此，我们在开发 Wilco 时研究的事情之一就是所谓的 CTA，即认知任务分析（Cognitive Task Analysis）。我们发现，消防员学习火灾理论以及在事故中该做什么，但当他们去到事故现场时，未必能够应用他们学到的理论，而一个拥有20年经验的消防员进入现场时，确切地知道该做什么以及如何去做，但他们无法将其教给别人。CTA 的作用就是试图提取这些知识、专家知识，
and turn that into something that could be handed off or could be taught to other people. And that combination of intuition, experience, wisdom, some people call it, is, you know, that's the elusive thing that we're trying to really give you with Wilco. This observation is really that the other fields do. I have some family in the medical field. And one of the interesting things is part of their degree is doing on the job sort of, you know, internships, as it were, I guess they call them other stuff. But they also do simulations where they bring in actual patients who have like a set of things they're supposed to say. And you say, oh, that's just testing their knowledge.
并将其转化为可以传授或教给其他人的东西。直觉、经验和智慧的结合（有些人称之为智慧），你知道，这就是我们真正试图通过 Wilco 带给你的那种难以捉摸的东西。这种观察确实是其他领域正在做的事情。我家里有人从事医疗行业。有趣的是，他们学位的一部分就是在职实习，差不多就是这样，我想他们叫别的名字。但他们也会进行模拟，引入真实的患者，这些人有一套必须说出的台词。你会说，这只是在测试他们的知识。
But actually, you can have something that sounds exactly like a very esoteric disease. But I think there's some phrase for it. I'll misquote it, so I'm not going to say it here. But the point being, like, there might be a much more mundane answer that could manifest the same way. And that's the one you should test first, not jump to the one in a million super rare mutation disease. Because all of them watched house and they think that, you know, that's the life of a doctor. Yes, because everyone comes off that training. And so it's this thing you said, which is one, extracting the knowledge, like teaching flows, they call it like differential diagnoses. Like,
但实际上，你可能会遇到一种听起来完全像某种极其晦涩的疾病的情况。我想它有一个专门的短语。我会引述错误，所以我就不在这里说了。但重点是，可能会有一个世俗得多的答案会导致同样的表现。这才是你首先应该测试的，而不是直接跳到百万分之一的超罕见变异疾病上去。因为他们所有人都看过《豪斯医生》，并认为那就是医生的生活。是的，因为每个人都是从那样的培训中出来的。所以这就是你刚才说的，第一，提取知识，比如教学流程，他们称之为鉴别诊断（differential diagnosis）。比如，
how do you decide between A and B? What is the test to apply? What is the choices? But then also not stopping there and teaching it, but actually putting them in a, you know, more complex, more messy case with real humans who don't describe things accurately or, you know, no, I don't have a cough, you know, and sort of like, yeah, you're getting contradictory inputs. And so what do you do then? A friend told me once, he gave me a great analogy. He said that if he wants to understand the state of the art in medicine, he's going to go to someone who just graduated med school. But if he needs someone to operate on his shoulder, then, you know, he's going to go to a
你如何在 A 和 B 之间做出决定？要应用什么测试？有哪些选择？但随后并不止步于此并进行教学，而是真正将他们置于一个更复杂、更混乱的案例中，面对那些无法准确描述情况的真实人类——比如“不，我没有咳嗽”之类的。你会得到相互矛盾的输入。那么你该怎么办？一位朋友曾告诉我一个很好的比喻。他说，如果他想了解医学的最新前沿水平，他会去找刚从医学院毕业的人；但如果他需要有人为他的肩膀做手术，那么，
doctor with or surgeon with 15 years of experience and that surgeon might actually know less than the recent grad but they've been there done that and and you know software engineering is like that there's a difference between knowing the state of the art and actually being able to practice it well cool all right so tell us a bit about Wilco as a company too so we talked about it as a as a sort of product and solution and, and sounds very engaging. Um, and we'll include in the show notes, but you can go to try Wilco.com and check it out, but talk to us about, about Wilco as a company. Are you guys hiring interns? Like what is the kind of behind the scenes of creating these quests? It sounds really interesting. Like how's all that powered? Yeah, it's, it's, it's, you know, I'm biased, but I think it's really cool. And writing a quest, you know, is a combination of understanding the the skill you want to practice or the lesson that you want to convey. But also tying that into a narrative and, and, and making
他会去找一个有15年经验的医生或外科医生，而这位外科医生实际知道的最新技术可能比应届毕业生还要少，但他们身经百战，经验丰富。你知道，软件工程也是如此。了解最新技术与真正能够熟练运用它之间是有区别的。好了，跟我们讲讲 Wilco 这家公司吧。我们把它当成一种产品和解决方案来讨论，听起来非常吸引人。我们会把它放在节目shownotes里，你可以访问 tryWilco.com 去看看。但跟我们聊聊 Wilco 这家公司吧。你们在招聘实习生吗？创建这些任务的幕后故事是什么样的？听这一切感觉真的很有趣，这些都是怎么驱动的？是的，这，这，你知道，我有偏见，但我认为这真的很酷。编写任务，你知道，是将你想要练习的技能或想要传达的教训结合起来的过程。但同时也要将其融入叙事中，并确保
sure that it's part of a curriculum, you can go on Wilco, you can practice all sorts of things. And, and it's not, you know, you use your own tools. So, you know, you're going to use your command line, you're going to use your IDE. But you might be using an observability tool, for example, because you need to maintain production. That's something that you don't do in college, right? But it's not just for college grads, right? You might be doing 20 years of programming in a different field and you're coming into something new or you're just looking to practice. So you're going to touch upon different tools and all of that. And of course, you could also be building your own.
它是课程的一部分。你可以在 Wilco 上练习各种各样的东西。而且，你知道，你要使用你自己的工具。所以，你知道，你要使用你的命令行，你要使用你的 IDE。但你可能也会使用可观测性工具，例如，因为你需要维护生产环境。这是你在大学里不会做的事情，对吧？但这不仅适用于大学毕业生，对吧？你可能在另一个领域有20年的编程经验，正在接触新事物，或者只是想练习。因此，你会接触到不同的工具以及所有这些。当然，你也可以构建你自己的。
So we don't have it just yet, but very soon we'll have an editor where you could be writing your own quests and contribute that to sort of the Wilco ecosystem. We already have companies that have built quests and they're on the platform, but in the future, we'll open this up to individuals as well. Very cool. Very cool. Do you guys, for hiring, are you looking for people who are like strictly like very senior established and ready to sort of impart what they've learned? Or you're looking for up and coming people to help build out the out the things that build the i mean i guess it becomes a eat your own dog food kind of thing well where do you guys kind of do most of your hiring since we're you know all about developing developers you know it would be very hypocritical of us if if we wouldn't
所以我们现在还没有，但很快我们就会有一个编辑器，你可以在那里编写自己的任务，并将其贡献给 Wilco 的生态系统。我们已经有一些公司构建了任务并将其放在了平台上，但在未来，我们也会向个人开放这一点。非常酷。非常酷。你们在招聘时，是在寻找那种非常资深、已经确立地位并准备传授他们所学知识的人？还是在寻找正在崛起的人来帮助构建这些构建内容？我的意思是，这大概变成了“吃自己的狗粮”这种事情。你们的大部分招聘都在哪里进行？既然我们，你知道，全部致力于培养开发者，你知道，如果我们
be open to people of all experience levels and we think that wilco is a great way for them to bridge that gap and and you know very gain experience. So we're really open to all experience levels, that's the kind of people that we want on our side. And actually, you know, being inexperienced in many ways has sort of an advantage of, you know, being able to call out things that we take for granted and might be tough on, you know, people who don't, you know, haven't exercised that skill or learned that area. Awesome. Well, this has been a great conversation on, you know, we covered a lot of ground. We put a lot of sidetracks aside and sort of we tried to stay on track a bit. But sidetrack is my middle name. Oh, there we go.
对所有经验水平的人都不开放，那将是非常虚伪的。我们认为 Wilco 是他们弥合这一差距并获得经验的绝佳途径。所以我们真的对所有经验水平的人都持开放态度，这正是我们想要加入我们团队的人。而且实际上，你知道，在许多方面，缺乏经验反而有一种优势，那就是能够指出那些我们认为理所当然的事情，而这些事情对于没有练习过该技能或学习过该领域的人来说可能很艰难。太棒了。好吧，这是一次很棒的对话，我们涵盖了很多领域。我们把很多岔路抛在一边，试图保持在正轨上。不过，“岔路（sidetrack）”是我的中间名。哦，原来如此。
Oh, I did. I see what you did there. Okay, well, there's our pun of the day. And so thanks for coming on the show. think people are really gonna like this i think it was a a thoughtful thing you know as a as a junior engineer i made a lot of really dumb mistakes i you know sometimes i wish i had the exposure to the things i i think are around now but to be honest probably wouldn't have paid attention to them. But maybe maybe we'll catch the person who thinks they don't need it. But you know, maybe maybe kind of puts a bit of extra thought into it today. But yeah, great advice all around. Thanks for being on the show. You know,
哦，我懂了。我看到你在那里的谐音梗了。好吧，这就是我们今天的双关语。感谢你来到节目。我想人们会真的很喜欢这个节目。我认为这是一个深思熟虑的话题。作为一个初级工程师，我犯过很多非常愚蠢的错误。你知道，有时我希望自己能接触到那些现在似乎已经存在的东西，但说实话，当时可能也不会去注意它们。不过，也许，也许我们会抓住那个自认为不需要它的人，但你知道，也许今天能让他们多想一想。总之，整体上是非常棒的建议。感谢你来到节目。你知道，
I think it's, it's been an awesome time. Thank you. Thank you so much. It's been it's been really great. And thanks for having me on the show. All right. We'll see everyone next time. See you later. Music by Eric Barndollar. Programming Throwdown is distributed under a Creative Commons Attribution Share Alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我认为这是一段非常美好的时光。谢谢你。非常感谢。真的很棒。感谢邀请我参加节目。好的，我们下次节目再见。再见。音乐由 Eric Barndollar 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 许可证下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，以及混音、改编作品，但你必须向帕特里克和我提供署名，并以相同方式分享。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可留下评论。